test test test test test
test test test test test test
test test test
test test test test
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
FRIENDS OF THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS, STUDENTS, STAFF,
EVERYONE WHO IS JOINING US LIVE
ON THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS'S
YOUTUBE CHANNEL, I'M KAREN
LLOYD, DIRECTOR OF THE VETERANS
HISTORY PROJECT HERE AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF
YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE TO COME SEE
NEW YORK TIMES BEST SELLING
AUTHOR, LIZA MUNDY, WHO IS GOING
TO DISCUSS HER BOOK, "CODE
GIRLS:  THE UNTOLD STORY OF
AMERICAN WOMEN CODE BREAKERS OF
WORLD WAR II" WE WERE PLANNING
TO HOLD THE EVENT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE MONTH.
MOTHER NATURE INTERVENED.
SO WE'RE HERE A FEW WEEKS LATER
AND MORE DETERMINED THAN EVER TO
SHINE THE SPOTLIGHT ON WOMEN WHO
HAVE MADE MAJOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OUR SOCIETY.
WE KNOW IT'S NEVER TOO LATE TO
CELEBRATE THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
WOMEN, AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE LIBRARIAN OF COPPING
DR. CARLA HADEN AND HER
LEADERSHIP TEAM FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO HELPING US WITH
THIS EPIDEFER.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK DOUG
BENNETT RETURNING TO WASHINGTON
TO BE WITH US TODAY.
TODAY'S EVENTS WILL FOCUS NOT
JUST ON WOMEN BUT ON WOMEN
VETERANS, WHO RAISED THEIR RIGHT
HAND, TOOK AN OATH TO SUPPORT
AND DEFEND OUR COUNTRY, PUT ON A
UNIFORM AND ACHIEVED AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHILE ENDURING
MANY SACRIFICES.
YOU'RE GOING THE HEAR THEIR
STORIES TODAY AND HOPEFULLY YOU
WILL LEARN ABOUT OTHERS IN YOUR
STUDY OR THROUGH THE MANY
RESOURCES WE HAVE HERE AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
AS YOU DO, KEEP IN MIND THAT
THERE ARE THOUSANDS MORE WOMEN
VETERANS WHOSE NAMES AND STORIES
MAY NEVER BE HER.
UNLESS YOU REACH OUT TO THE
VETERANS IN YOUR LIVES AND YOUR
COMMUNITIES TO LISTEN, REALLY
LISTEN TO THEIR STORY AND DONATE
IT TO THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
THE VETERANS HISTORY PROJECT
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK OUR
CO-SPONSOR, THE LIBRARIES YOUNG
READERS CENTER, DEVOTED TO
READING INTERESTS ISES OF
CHILDREN AND TEENS THE YOUNG
READERS SENTE OFFERS YOUNG
PEOPLE AND FAMILIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE THE
WONDERS AND RESOURCES OF THE
NATION'S LIBRARY TO ONGOING
PROGRAMS AND SPECIAL EVENTS.
THEY WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING US REACH TOUT SCHOOLS SO
-- OUT TO SCHOOLS SO THEIR
SCHOOLS WILL BENEFIT FROM
TODAY'S TALK AND TO DEVELOP A
DEEPER APPRECIATION FOR PRIMARY
SOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM HERE AT LIBRARY BUT
ESPECIALLY THE VETERANS HISTORY
PROJECT.
WITH MORE THAN 105,000
COLLECTIONS IN OUR ARCHIVES, THE
VETERAN HISTORY PROJECT
COLLECTS, PRESERVES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, MAKES ACCESSIBLE
THE STORY OF THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY VETERANS WHO SERVED IN
WORLD WAR I THROUGH THE CURRENT
CONFLICTS.
SO THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS MAY
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THOSE
VETERANS AND BETTER UNDERSTAND
THEIR SELFLESS SERVICE.
OUR COLLECTIONS INCLUDE VIDEO
AND AUDIO ORAL HISTORY
INTERVIEWS ALONG WITH ORIGINAL
PHOTOGRAPHS, LETTERS, MILITARY
DOCUMENTS, DIARIES, YOURNAL --
YOUR
HONORNALS AND TWO DIMENSION --
JOURNALS AND TWO DIMENSIONAL
ART.
WE CONTINUE TO SOLICIT
VOLUNTEERS LIKE YOU FROM ACROSS
THE NATION TO GATHER THEIR
STORIES OF VETERANS IN THEIR
LIVES SO THAT THEIR FIRST PERSON
RECOMMENDSISES, -- REMINISCES,
PERSONAL PHILOSOPHIES ARE
PRESERVED FOR POSTERITY.
IN DOING SO WE ALL BETTER
UNDERSTAND HISTORY.
TODAY'S GUEST PRESENTER CAN I A
TEST TO THE VALUE OF OUR
COLLECTIONS BECAUSE SHE USED
THEM WHEN CONDUCTING RESEARCH
FOR HER BOOK.
AS A FORMER LONG TIME REPORTER
AT THE WASHINGTON POST, LIZA
MUNDY IS NO STRANGER TO
RESEARCH.
A SENIOR FELLOW AT NEW AMERICA,
HER EXPLORATION OF ISSUES
RELATED TO WOMEN IN WAR RESULTED
IN HER EMERGE MERGING AS ONE OF
THE NATION'S FOR MOST EXPERTS ON
THE SUBJECT.
SHE'S A FREQUENT COMMENTATOR ON
PROMINENT NATIONAL TELEVISION
SHOW, RADIO AND ONLINE NEWS
OUTLETS.
SHE HAS CONTRIBUTED TO NUMEROUS
PUBLICATIONS INCLUDING THE
ATLANTIC, TIME, NEW REPUBLIC,
SLATE, MOTHER JONES, AND
POLITICO.
THERE'S A RANGE.
IN ADDITION TO "CODE GIRLS"
SHE'S OS AUTHOR OF THE RICHER
SEX HOW FEMALE BREADWINNERS IS
TRANSFORMING SEX LOVE AND
ALSO
BIOGRAPHY.
AFTER HER PRESENTATION SHE'S
GRACIOUS HI AGREED TO STAY WITH
US A WHILE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
FROM THE AUDIENCE AND TO SIGN
COPIES OF HER BOOK WHICH ARE
AVAILABLE FOR PURCHASE OUTSIDE
THIS ROOM.
NOW PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
TO THE PODIUM OUR SPECIAL GUEST
LIZA MUNDY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, WENDY FOR
THAT GREAT INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY WHO CAME
FOR THE RESCHEDULED EVENT.
THANK YOU, LISA TAYLOR, YOU HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLY HOSPITABLE AND
ORGANIZED IN HELPING WITH MY
RESEARCH AND THIS EVENT.
IT'S A THRILL TO SPEAK AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS, OBVIOUSLY
ONE OF THE GREAT RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS IN THE WORLD.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THE
VETERANS HISTORY COLLECTION HERE
WAS SO FUNDAMENTALLY CRUCIAL TO
MY RESEARCH.
WHEN I WAS GETTING STARTED,
RESEARCHING CODE GIRLS AND WHEN
I WAS IN FACT SHOPPING THE BOOK
PROPOSAL, TO EDITORS IN NEW
YORK, APPARENTLY ONE OF THE
EDITORS SAID THAT HE THOUGHT
THAT IT WAS A GREAT STORY BUT
FELT IT MIGHT BE THIN BEER
BECAUSE SO MUCH TIME PASSED
SINCE WORLD WAR II, IF THERE
WERE ANY WOMEN CODE BREAKERS OUT
THERE THEY WOULD BE IN MID
'90s, MAYBE WOULDN'T REMEMBER
MUCH, WOULDN'T BE MUCH RECORD
SINCE IT WAS TOP SECRET WORK.
SO I GOT UP EVERY DAY DURING
RESEARCH AND SAID I A HE I'LL
SHOW YOU.
I HAVE THE HELP OF ALLIES LIKE
THE VETERANS HISTORY COLLECTION
HERE, I LITERALLY EMAILED
THROUGH THE WEBSITE SAYING I'M
WORKING ON THIS BOOK, DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING, ININSTANTLY GOT A
REPLY FROM MEGAN HARRIS SAYING
YES, WE HAVE WONDERFUL RECORDS,
WE HAVE ORAL HISTORIES, WE HAVE
SUPPLEMENTARY MATERIALS, SHE
PROVIDED ME WITH A LIST OF THE
NAMES OF WOMEN THEY TAKEN ORAL
HISTORIES FROM, INCREDIBLY WELL
ORGANIZED, I CAME HERE FOR
SEVERAL DAYS AND LISTENED AND
READ TO THE WOMEN'S WHO TOLD
THEIR STORIES, MANY NO LONGER
WITH US BUT FORT FORTUNATELY
STORIES
ARE COLLECTED AND RESIDE HERE
DIGITALLY SO IN THE END I WAS
ABLE TO COLLECT ALMOST MORE
MATERIAL THAN I COULD COPE WITH
IN REPORTING THIS BOOK.
FOR LIVING WOMEN AND FROM
WONDERFUL ARCHIVAL RESOURCES
LIKE THIS COLLECTION AND ABLE TO
SUBSTANDIATE THE RECOLLECTIONS
OF WOMEN WHO ARE STILL ALIVE
WITH THE PAPER RECORD, WITH ORAL
HISTORY AND OTHER SUPPLEMENTARY
INFORMATION SO I'M SO GRATEFUL
FOR THIS INSTITUTION FOR MAKING
AMERICAN HISTORY ACCESSIBLE TO
RESEARCHERS, TO CITIZENS, TO
EVERYBODY AND FOR HOLDING EVENTS
LIKE THIS WHERE WE CAN CONTINUE
GET THE MESSAGE OUT AND SUPPORTK
AUTHORINGS WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT:  SO IT'S THRILLING TO
BE HERE.
IT'S ALSO THRILL TO BE HERE
DURING WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
ORIGINALLY I WAS GOING TO BE
SPEAKING AT THE BEGINNING OF
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH AND NOW WE
HAVE MANAGED TO SNEAK IN THE
RESCHEDULED EVENT WHEN IT'S
STILL MARCH, THAT'S MEANINGFUL
BECAUSE WE'RE T A WATER SHED
MOMENT IN TERMS OF RECEPTIVITY
TO WOMEN WITH'S'S HISTORY.
IT SHOULD BE EVERYBODY'S HISTORY
MONTH BUT THIS MONTH HAS SPECIAL
MEANING AND I THINK WE'RE IN A
GREAT MOMENT.
BOOK LIKES HIDDEN FIGURES SO
SUCCESSFUL IN OPENING UP THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WOMEN HAVE
MADE TO AMERICAN MILITARY
HISTORY, TO AMERICAN SCIENCE,
HAVE REALLY PERSUADE PUBLISHERS
THAT THERE'S AN AUDIENCE FOR
THESE BOOKS, PEOPLE RECEPTIVE TO
THESE STORIES.
YOU NAY KNOW THE NEW YORK TIMES
START AD SERIES CALLED
OVERLOOKED GOING BACK TO
ARCHIVAL RECORD AND REALIZING
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WOMEN
PASSED FROM THE SCENE AND DIDN'T
GET OBITUARIES INCLUDING
CHARLOTTE BRANTE, WOMEN OF THAT
STATURE WEREN'T RECOGNIZED
DURING THAT U TIME SO THE NEW
YORK TIME HAD A NEW SERIES WHICH
THEY'RE GOING BACK AND PROVIDING
OBITUARIES OF WOMEN WHO SHOULD
HAVE GOTTEN RECOGNITION IN THEIR
TIME.
AND I FEEL THE PUBLISHING
INDUSTRY IS DOING THE SAME THING
TODAY, SO IS IT'S THRILLING TO
BE PART OF IT.
SO WHEN TALKING ABOUT CODE
GIRLS, ABOUT THESE THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN WHO CAME TO WASHINGTON TO
JOIN THE U.S. MILITARY AND
SUPPORT THE WAR EFFORT, I LIKE
TO START WITH THIS SLIDE,
BECAUSE IT REALLY ILLUSTRATES
THE PLIGHT OF THE EDUCATED WOMAN
IN 1942.
THIS PHOTO SHOWS THE MAY COURT
AT GOWNER COLLEGE IN THE SPRING
OF 1942, SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
GOUCHER COLLEGE THEN WAS AND ALL
GIRLS SCHOOL, THE WOMEN WHO WENT
THERE WERE CALLED GOUCHER GIRLS,
LOCATED IN DOWNTOWN BALTIMORE,
D. CM, IT'S A CO-EDUCATIONAL
UNIVERSITY BUT AT THE TIME IT
WAS A CITY SCHOOL, MANY YOUNG
WOMEN WHO ATTENDED THERE WERE
CITY GIRLS WHO GREW UP IN
BALTIMORE, WHO WALKED TO
CLASSES, IN SOME CASES COULDN'T
AFFORD TO BOARD BECAUSE THEY HAD
GROWN UP DURING THE DEPRESSION
AND WERE VERY DEVOTED AND
MOTIVATED TO GET A GREAT LIBERAL
ARTS EDUCATION.
GOUCHER WAS A WELL RESPECTED
UNIVERSITY, ITS DEAN DOROTHY
STIPSON WAS A NOTED EXPERT ON
COPERNICUS, THE FIRST AMERICAN
WOMAN TO WIN PULL LESSER
TOP NOTCH SCHOOL.
THESE WOMEN WERE MORE UNUSUAL
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE KNOWN AT
THIS TIME IN AMERICAN LIFE 4% OF
AMERICAN WOMEN ATTAINED A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE DEGREE.
THE REASON THAT PERCENTAGE WAS
SO SMALL WAS IN PART BECAUSE SO
MANY SCHOOLS WERE SO CLOSED TO
WOMEN, SO MANY CAMPUSES DIDN'T
ADMIT WOMEN, THE IVY LEAGUE FOR
MOST PART WAS CLOSED TO WOMEN,
MANY, MANY PRIVATE UNIVERSITS,
MANY STATE UNIVERSITIES AND MY
HOME STATE OF VIRGINIA, THE
UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA DID NOT
GIVE FULL DEGREES TO WOMEN UNTIL
THE 1960s AND SO THERE WERE
NOT A LOT OF INSTITUTIONS TO
CHOOSE FROM AND OF COURSE THESE
WONDERFUL WOMEN'S COLLEGES HAD
BEEN FOUNDED IN LATE 19th
CENTURY AT A TIME WHEN MANY
BELIEVED HIGHER EDUCATION WAS
BAD FOR WOMEN, IT MADE WOMEN
SORT OF UPPITY AND OBNOXIOUS AND
THERE WAS ACTUALLY A BELIEF THAT
EDUCATION WASN'T GOOD FOR WOMEN,
TOO MUCH LEARNING WASN'T GOOD
FOR WOMEN.
THERE WAS A HARVARD PHYSICIAN
WHO ARGUED THAT TOO MUCH
EDUCATION MADE WOMEN INFER
UNTIL, THAT IT SWELLED THEIR
BRAINS AT THE EXPENSE OF THEIR
WOMBS, HE ARGUED THAT AND PEOPLE
BELIEVED IT.
SO THESE WOMEN COLLEGES HAD BEEN
CREATED AT A TIME WHEN THEY HAD
SOMETHING TO PROVE, THAT WOMEN
DO STERVED EDUCATION, IT WAS
WORTH EDUCATEK WOMEN AND IT WAS
GOOD FOR WOMEN TO BE EDUCATED.
ANOTHER REASON THE NUMBERS WERE
SO SMALL IS FAMILIES REALIZED
THIS THERE WAS NOT ECONOMIC PAY
OFF TO EDUCATING DAUGHTER THE
WAY THERE WAS FOR A SON BECAUSE
PROFESSIONAL FIELDS OPENED TO
EDUCATED WOMEN WERE SO LIMITED.
IF YOU WERE A WOMAN MOTIVATED TO
BECOME A DOCTOR OR LAWYER OR
ARCHITECT OR BUSINESSWOMAN OR
ENGINEER OR SCIENTIST, YOU WOULD
BE LUCKY THE FIND A SPOT IN A
GRADUATE SCHOOL.
MANY, MANY GRADUATE SCHOOLS WERE
CLOSED TO WOMEN, MANY FIELDS
WERE VIRTUALLY CLOSED TO WOMEN,
SO THE ONLY JOB YOU COULD EXPECT
GRADUATING FROM A FINE COLLEGE
REALLY RELIABLY WAS TEACHING
SCHOOL.
THAT'S GREAT IF YOU WANT TO BE A
SCHOOLTEACHER BUT IF THAT'S
ANOTHER FIELD YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN IT PRESENTS A NARROW FIELD OF
ENDEAVOR FOR WOMEN AND EVEN THEN
ONLY UNTIL YOU GET MARRIED CAN
YOU EXPECT A SCHOOL TEACHING
JOB.
BACK THEN THERE WAS A MARRIAGE
BAR SO IF A WOMAN GOT MARRIED
SHE WAS REQUIRED TO QUIT
TEACHING AND STAY HOME WITH HER
HODS AND FAMILY.
SO THERE WAS -- HUSBAND AND
FAMILY.
SO THERE WASN'T A GREAT ECONOMIC
PAY OFF TO GETTING A COLLEGE
DEGREE FOR WOMEN AND PARENT
COMING OUT OF THE DEPRESSION,
THEY MADE THAT CALCULATION.
OF COURSE, THE OTHER REASON FOR
A WOMAN TO GO TO COLLEGE FOR
WHICH THERE MIGHT BE AN ECONOMIC
PAY OFF WAS TO GET THE
PROVERBIAL MRS DEGREE.
WHICH WAS A THING BACK THEN, THE
IDEA THAT IF YOU WENT TO COLLEGE
THEN YOU COULD DATE MEN, AT
NEIGHBORING MEN'S SCHOOL, MARRY
A MAN FROM A GOOD FAMILY OR WITH
GOOD PROSPECTS AND YOU CAN GET
YOURSELF SITUATED IN LIFE, MAYBE
TEACH A COUPLE OF YEARS, PUT HIM
THROUGH LAW SCHOOL OR WHATEVER
BUT THERE WOULD BE AN ECONOMIC
PAY OFF TO MARRIAGE.
SO THESE YOUNG WOMEN WHO WERE
ACADEMICALLY MOTIVATED,
CHALLENGED BY THEIR CLASSESES
WERE PRESSURED PARTICULARLY IN
SENIOR YEAR TO GET ENGAGED, GET
THAT RING, TO HAVE THEIR FUTURE
ASSURED.
AND SO THESE SCHOOLS HAD
CEREMONIES LIKE THE MAY COURT,
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL, THE MAY
COURT WAS SOME REMNANT OF PAGAN
FERTILITY RITUAL WHICH THE YOUNG
WOMEN SELECTIVE BECAUSE OF THEIR
BEAUTY OR THEIR PERSONALITY OR
THEIR FAMILY OR THEIR ACADEMIC
STANDING WOULD BE ELECTED TO THE
MAY COURT.
YOU SEE THE QUEEN UP THERE IN
THE CHAIR.
AND THEY WOULD BE SORT OF
SYMBOLICALLY USHERED INTO THE
MARRIAGE MARKET.
ALL THE WOMEN'S COLLEGES HAD
RITUALS LIKE THIS.
WELLSLY COLLEGE IN MASSACHUSETTS
HAD SENIOR CLASS ROLE AND THE
LEGEND OF THE HOOP ROLL IS
WINNER WOULD BE THE CLASS'S
FIRST BRIDE.
SO THAT WAS A GREAT DISTINCTION.
AND SO -- AND I INTERVIEWED MANY
OF THESE WOMEN AND THEY REMEMBER
THE INTENSE PRESSURE TO GET
MARRIED AT THE TIME AND WELLSLY
HAD A SECTION OF THE YEARBOOK
THAT LISTED WOMEN AND THEIR
ENGAGEMENTS AND WHO THEY WERE
ENGAGED TO AS WELL AS WOMEN WHO
HAD GOTTEN MARRIED EVEN BEFORE
GRADUATING AND HAD LEFT COLLEGE
IN MANY CASES IN ORDER TO GET
MARRIED.
SO AGAIN, THAT GIVES YOU A SENSE
OF HOW HARD THESE WOMEN HAD
WORKED TO GET THEIR SCHOOLING,
BUT SORT OF THE VERY LIMITED
FIELD OF LIFE PROSPECTS THAT
THEY WERE LOOKING AT UPON
GRADUATION.
BUT WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR PHOTO IS THAT
UNBEKNOWNST TO ANYBODY,
INCLUDING THEIR COLLEAGUES ON
THE PLATFORM, TWO OF THESE
WOMEN, THIS IS JACQUELINE
JENKINS, THAT WAS HER NAME AT
THE TIME.
LATER ON WHEN SHE MARRIED SHE
WOULD BE JACQUELINE JENKINS NYE,
E,
THE MOTHER OF BILL NYE THE
SCIENCE GUY SO YOU CAN GET A
SENSE OF HER INTELLECTUAL CHOPS
AS WELL AS HER FRIEND GWENNETH,
THESE TWO YOUNG WOMEN WERE
SECRETLY SELECTED AND TAPPED BY
THE U.S. NAVY AND THEY WERE
RECEIVING TRAINING IN CRYPT
ANALYSIS, A FIELD THEY NEVER
HEARD OF, NOBODY HAD HEARD OF,
THEY WERE RECEIVING WEEKLY
INSTRUCTION IN A LOCKED
CLASSROOM AT THE TOP OF GOUCHE
HER
HALL, ONLY MAYBE CHAPTER AHEAD
IN THE CORRESPONDENCE COURSE THE
U.S. NAVY COMPILED TO TEACH THEM
THIS ARCANE FIELD, THAT HAD BEEN
AROUND SINCE TIME OF JULIUS
CAESAR OR PROBABLY SINCE TIME
LEARNING TO WRITE OR COMMUNICATE
AS ALL AS HUMANS BECAUSE IT IS
HUMAN INSTINCT TO SEND SECRET
COMMUNICATIONS TO SOMEBODY WHO
YOU HAVE AN URGENT MESSAGE FOR
AND NOT HAVE ANYBODY ELSE LISTEN
IN.
SO THIS FIELD HAD BEEN AROUND
REALLY FOR CENTURYIES BUT NOT SO
MUCH IN THE UNITED STATES AND
NOBODY REALLY IN THE MAINSTREAM
HAD HEARD OF IT.
SO THEY WERE BEING TAUGHT ALL OF
A SUDDEN IN GREAT SECRECY, THEY
COULDN'T TELL THEIR BROTHERS,
BOYFRIENDS, FAMILY MEMBERS, THEY
COULDN'T TELL THEIR ROOMMATES
WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
THEY WERE LEARNING HOW TO TAKE
FREQUENCY COUNTS, LEARNING
BEHAVIOR OF LETTERS IN THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE AND THE FRENCH
LANGUAGE, THEY WERE LEARNING HOW
AL TA
ALPHABETS COULD BE SCRAMBLED TO
DISGUISE SECRET COMMUNICATIONS.
THE REASON THAT WAS HAPPENING IS
BECAUSE IN DECEMBER OF 1941 ON
DECEMBER 7TH THE PACIFIC FLEET
WAS ATTACKED AT PARTIAL HARBOR,
IT WAS A GREAT SHOCK AND
SURPRISE TO THE NEIGH, THE
WORLD, -- NATION, THE WORLD, IT
WAS A SURPRISE ATTACK, WE HADN'T
SEEN IT COMING, WE LOST
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG AMERICAN
SERVICEMEN.
AND SO WE WERE LAUNCHED FORMALLY
INTO WORLD WAR II, IT HAD BEEN
RAGING IN EUROPE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS, WE KNEW THAT WE WERE
GOING TO JOIN THE FIGHTING AT
SOME POINT BUT WE DIDN'T KNOW
THAT IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
ABRUPTLY AFTER DECEMBER 7TH.
THE NEXT DAY OF COURSE CONGRESS
DECLARES WAR ON JAPAN.
THREE DAYS LATER GERMANY
DECLARES WAR ON US.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN U.S. IS
LAUNCHED INTO WHAT WAS CALLED
TOTAL WAR, ALL THE YOUNG MEN
SIGNED UP TO FIGHT.
JAPAN THOUGHT THE ATTACK AT
PEARL HARBOR WOULD BRING US TO
YOU ARE KNEES, DEMORALIZE US, IT
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO KEEP
HOLDINGS IN THE PACIFIC THEY
WERE CONQUERING EVEN IF THEY
WERE BOMBING PEARL HARBOR AND IT
HAD THE OPPOSITE EFFECT ON THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
WE ROSE UP IN ARMS, EVERY FAMILY
WAS DETERMINED TO CONTRIBUTE TO
WAR EFFORT, EVERY YOUNG MAN
WANTED TO BE IN MILITARY UNIFORM
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN ALL THE
YOUNG MEN WERE SHIPPING TO THE
PACIFIC TO ISLANDS, THAT MOST
AMERICANS HAD NEVER HEARD OF TO
THE EUROPEAN THEATER ON CONVOYS
GOING TO EUROPE.
IT WAS EVACUATION OF THE MEN.
SO AT THE SAME TIME THAT
SUDDENLY WE'RE FIGHTING THESE
BATTLES, STRUNG OUT THOUSANDS OF
MILES AROUND THE WORLD, WE KNOW
THAT WE HAD NO INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES, WE HAD NO WAY OF
KNOWING WHEN THERE WAS GOING TO
BE ANOTHER ENEMY ATTACK.
WHERE THE ENEMY IS LOCATED.
WE WANT TO ATTACK.
IT'S VERY HARD TO SORT OF
BELIEVE THIS IN THE DAY IN TIME
WE HAVE 17 INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
IN WASHINGTON D.C., WE HAD NONE
OF THOSE WHEN ENTERED WORLD WAR
II, WHEN WE NEEDED INTELLIGENCE
MORE THAN WE EVER HAD WE DIDN'T
HAVE A CIA AN NSA, WE DIDN'T
HAVE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, WE HAVE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES NOW WHOSE
JOB IS TO OVERSEE OTHER
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.  WE DEN
HAVE THAT THEN.
WE FORM THE OSS QUICKLY TO BEGIN
TO BUILD A SPY NETWORK OVERSEAS
BUT ONE THING WE COULD DO RIGHT
AWAY IS RAMP UP OUR ABILITY TO
INTERCEPT THE RADIO SIGNALS THE
ENCRYPTED ENCODED RADIO
SIGNALINGS THAT MILITARY
COMMANDERS THAT POLITICIANS THAT
DIP MATS WERE SENDING THROUGH
THE AIRWAVES THOUSANDS OF
MESSAGES ON A DAILY BASIS,
ANNOUNCING THEIR WHEREABOUTS AND
ANNOUNCING THEIR PLANS,
DISCUSSING THEIR STRATEGY, ALL
OF THIS WAS TRAVELING THROUGH
THE AIRWAVES, RADIOS SOMETIMES
BY TELEGRAPH, SEND BY MORSE CODE
AND ENCRYPTED SUCH AS LIKE OUR
TEXT EMAILS, INSTAGRAMS, OUR
TWEETS, ARE ALL ENCRYPTED, THAT
WAS WHAT WAS HAPPENING AS ALL
THESE MILITARIES WERE STRUNG OUT
ALL OVER THE WORLD SO ADMIRAL
DONITS COMMANDING THE U BOAT
LEAGUE COMMANDING EACH U BOAT,
IS SENDING MESSAGES EVERY DAY.
WE WANTED TO KNOW HOW TO BREAK
THOSE CODE BREAKING.
THE U.S. ARM MY AND NAVY BEFORE
THE WAR WE NEEDED TO SCALE UP
BASICALLY, WE NEED TO SCALE
THOSE OPERATIONS IN A MASSIVE
WAY, AND EXACTLY THE TIME THE
EDUCATED YOUNG MEN THAT THE
MILITARY NORMALLY WOULD HAVE
TURNED TO TO DO THIS WORK WERE
SUDDENLY UNAVAILABLE BECAUSE
THEY WERE FIGHTING.
SO THE U.S. MILITARY MAKES A
DECISION, IF THE EDUCATED YOUNG
MEN ARE UNAVAILABLE TO US LET'S
GIVE THE WOMEN A CHANCE.
LET'S OPEN UP SOME FIELDS OF
ENDEAVOR TO SMART MOTIVATED
WOMEN.
SO WHEN I WAS DOING MY WORK ALSO
AT THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES IN
COLLEGE PARK WHICH IS A
WONDERFUL RESEARCH FACILITY, AND
IT'S THE OPPOSITE OF -- THERE
ARE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
RECORDS AT NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
I FOUND THIS, WITH SOME
BUREAUCRAT AT THE U.S. NAVY GOT
THE BRIGHT IDEA THE NAVY HAD A
SMALL CORRESPONDENCE COURSE
GOING ON FOR YEARS WHICH THEY
WOULD RECRUIT DABBLERS IN
CRYPTOLOGY, THEY WOULD TRY TO
BRING IN HOBBIESTISTS, PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT JOIN CIVILIAN CODE
BREAKING FORCE IN THE '30s SO
THEY HAD A COURSE ALREADY AND
THEY PERIODICALLY PRODUCE MEMOS
SAYING WHERE THEY WERE LOOKING
FOR THESE KINDS OF PEOPLE, THESE
PARTICULAR KINDS OF BRAINS, THEY
WANTED.
SO YOU CAN SEE THIS MEMO SAYS
NEW SOURCE WOMEN'S COLLEGES.
SO THOUGH THE LIGHT BULB WENT ON
AND SOMEBODY SAID LET'S SEE WHAT
THE WOMEN CAN DO.
AND IF THEY CAN DO THIS WORK.
AND THE RESULT OF THIS MEMO AND
THE DECISION AND THE FEAR IN THE
U.S. NAVY THAT ANOTHER ATTACK
WOULD HAPPEN LIKE PEARL HARBOR,
THIS WAS A GREAT INTELLIGENCE
FAILURE, THE NAVY KNEW THAT,
CAREERS WERE ENDED.
PEOPLE FELT ENORMOUS GUILT, THEY
COULDN'T LET THIS HAPPEN.
SO IN A MOMENT OF DESPERATION
AND CRISIS, LET'S BE INCLUSIVE.
LET'S BRING IN THE WOMEN.
SO AS A RESULT OF THIS, WOMEN
NOT ONLY AT GOUCHER BUT AT THE
SEVEN SISTERS COLLEGES ON THE
EASTERN SEA BOARD, ELITE WOMEN'S
COLLEGES SEEN BY NAVY AS COUNTER
PART TO THE MALE IVY LEAGUE,
SENIOR WOMEN WHO WERE IDENTIFIED
BY THEIR DEANS AND PROFESSORS
OFTEN MATH PROFESSOR AND
ASTRONOMY PROFESSORS IDENTIFY
YOUNG WOMEN TALENTED AT MATH
SCIENCE AND LAINGIAN ALSO SHOWED
GRIT, PERSISTENCE, SHOWED
WILLINGNESS TO OVERCOME
FRUSTRATION, THEY WOULD SECRETLY
TAP THESE WOMEN, WOULD BE CALLED
IN TO THEIR GREAT SURPRISE AND
ASKED TWO QUESTIONS.
DO YOU LIKE CROSS WORD PUDDLES
AND ARE YOU ENGAGED TO BE
MARRIED?
IF THEY ANSWERED YES TO THE
FIRST AND NO TO THE SECOND, THEY
WOULD BE INVITED TO TAKE THIS
SECRET NAVAL CRYPT ANALYTIC
TRAINING COURSE IN SECRECY
ADULTER COURSE OF THEIR
SECRET DURING
THE SENIOR YEAR.
MEN WERE SHIPPING OUT WAY WANTED
SOMEBODY WAITING AT HOME AND
SOMEBODY TO WRITE TO SO A LOT OF
WOMEN LIED AND THOUGH THEY WERE
ENGAGED, WHATEVER THEY WERE
BEING INVITED TO DO SOUNDED MORE
INTERESTING THAN SITTING AROUND
WAITING TO SEE IF THEIR BROTHERS
WOULD BE OKAY OR BOYFRIENDS
WOULD BE OKAY, THEY WANTED TO
JOIN THE WAR EFFORT.
SO THEY LIED SAID THEY WEREN'T
ENGAGED, TOOK COURSE AND CAME TO
WASHINGTON D.C. TO WORK IN
JUNE 1942 AT THE TIME THE PADDLE
OF MIDWAY, ONE OF THE GREAT --
BATTLE OF MIDWAY, GREAT SEA
BATTLE, THE FIRST PAY BACK FOR
PEARL HARBOR, SHOWED THE U.S.
MILITARY SECRETLY, BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC DIDN'T KNOW OR SHOULDN'T
KNOW, HOW IMPORTANT CODE
BREAKING WAS GOING TO BE TO THE
WAR EFFORT.
THIS WAS A TIME WHEN WE DID NOT
KNOW THAT WE WERE GOING TO WIN
WOULD WAR II, IT WAS NOT A
CONCLUSION.
THERE WAS ENORMOUS CONCERN WE
MIGHT NOT PREVAIL, THE ATLANTIC
COAST WAS BESIEGED BY U BOATS,
THERE WAS FEAR IN THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC BUT THE BATTLE OF THE
MIDWAY WAS THE TURNING POINT AND
TURNED ON BRILLIANT CODE
BREAKING THAT WARNED US THE
JAPANESE WERE EN ROUTE TO AMBUSH
AND FINISH US OFF AND INSTEAD WE
AMBUSHED THE JAPANESE FLEET AND
WON THAT BATTLE SO THAT SIGNAL
PEOPLE NEEDED TO KNOW CODE
BREAKING WAS IMPORTANT AND THE
WOMEN STARTED POURING IN AT THE
MOMENT WHEN YOU KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS WAS GOING TO BE.
MEANWHILE THE U.S. ARMY ALSO
NEEDS TO COMPETE FOR EDUCATED
WOMEN.
BECAUSE THE SET UP AT OUR ENTRY
INTO THE WAR IS THAT THE UK HAS
LEAD CODE BREAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE ATLANTIC
OCEAN AND THE EUROPEAN THEATER.
SO IF YOU HAVE SEEN THE
IMITATION GAME YOU HEARD THE
OTHER GREAT CODE BREAKING
SUCCESS WHICH IS OUR BREAKING OF
THE ENIGMA CIPHER, ENGLAND
BREAKING OF THE ENIGMA CIPHER
AND THE ABILITY TO READ THE
GERMAN MESSAGES THAT WERE
CONTROLLING THE U BOATS AS WELL
AS MOVEMENT.
S OF THE AIR FORCE AND ARMY.
WHEN WE ENTER THE WERE WAR WE
HAVE A VESTED STAKE AS WELL
BECAUSE WE'RE SENDING OUR BOYS
TO THE ATLANTIC WHICH IS RIDDLED
WITH U BOATS SO WE CARE, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO BE THE JUNIOR
PARTNER IN THAT CODE BREAKING
EFFORT BUT MEANWHILE WE HAVE
LEAD AND REALLY SOLE CODE
BREAKING RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
VAST, VAST PACIFIC OCEAN.
SO THE U.S. NAVY JUST RECRUITED
THE WOMEN FROM THE SEVEN SISTERS
SCHOOL IS GOING TO BE WORKING
PRIMARILY JAPANESE NAVAL FLEET
CODE, WITH MAJOR CODE SYSTEM
THAT IS BEING USED BY THE
JAPANESE NAVY.
BUT THE JAPANESE ARMY HAD A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SYSTEM AND
THEY'RE SPREAD OUT ALL OVER THE
PACIFIC, THEY HAVE TAKEN THE
FILL PHILIPPINES, ISLANDS AROUND
THE PACIFIC, LAND MASSES AND
AGAIN, THEY'RE COMMUNICATING
THROUGH SIGNALS.
OUR U.S. ARMY HAS RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THOSE SIGNAL SIGNAL SYSTEMS
AND
THEY NEED TO RECRUIT WOMEN AS
WELL SO THEY FIGURE THEY MAKE A
DIFFERENT CALCULATION.
OKAY, OUR COMPETITORS IN THE
U.S. NAVY HAVE THE EASTERN SEA
BOARD AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
COMPETE FOR SCHOOLTEACHERS, TURN
TO TEACHING COLLEGES.
WHICH WERE THE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS THAT EXISTED TO
EDUCATE WOMEN.
FOR EXAMPLE, DOROTHY RAMALI I
INTERVIEWED FOR MY BOOK WAS AT
INDIANA STATE TEACHERS COLLEGE
IN PENNSYLVANIA, SHE HAD GROWN
UP IN RURAL PENNSYLVANIA, SHE
WANTED TO BE A MATH TEACHER,
THAT WAS A AMBITIOUS ASPIRATION
FOR A WOMAN BECAUSE WOMEN WERE
NOT ENCOURAGED TO GO INTO MATH,
THEY WERE SOMETIMES NOT HIRED AS
TEACHERS BUT THAT'S WHAT SHE
WANTED TO DO, THAT WAS HER
PASSION AND SHE WAS CALLED IN BY
THE DEAN OF WOMEN AND INVITED
THE TAKE THE ARMY SECRET CRYPT
ANALYTIC TRAINING COURSE.
BUT EVEN WOMEN IN TEACHERS
COLLEGES WEREN'T ENOUGH FOR THE
ENORMOUS CODE BREAKING
OPERATIONS THAT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE TO ESTABLISH.
SO THE ARMY DECIDED TO ALSO GO
AFTER SCHOOLTEACHERS YOUNG WOMEN
WHO WERE ACTUALLY TEACHING
SCHOOL.
THEY WERE GOING TO BE YOUNG,
HARD WORKING, THEY WERE GOING TO
BE SINGLE, THEY WERE GOING TO BE
WELL EDUCATE AND THEY WERE GOING
TO BE UNDERPAID.
SO THEY WERE GOING TOABLE
BE
EXTREMELY MOTIVATED TO TAKE
BETTER PAY WORK WITH THE WAR
DEPARTMENT SO THE ARMY STRATEGY
WAS TO -- AND I LITERALLY FOUND
ORAL HISTORY, WHICH COMMANDERS
CONGRATULATED THEMSELVES FOR
THEIR STRATEGY, THEY WERE THINK
THINKING THAT THEY DECIDE TO
SEND THEIR HANDSOMEST YOUNG ARMY
OFFICERS OUT TO LURK IN HOTELS
AND POST OFFICES, RECRUITING
STATIONS PARTICULARLY AROUND THE
AMERICAN SOUND.
THEY WERE RECRUITING WOMEN AS
CIVILIANS AND THE BUREAUCRATIC
RULES CONFINE TO NORTH CAROLINA,
SOUTH CAROLINA WEST VIRGINIA,
THINKING WAS SOUTHERN WOMEN WERE
PARTICULARLY SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
CHARMS OF A HANDS SOME MAN AND
THAT ALL THESE HARD WORKING
SMART YOUNG SCHOOLTEACHERS WOULD
BE MOTIVATED TO COME TO
WASHINGTON TO DO SECRET WAR WORK
THINKING THEY WOULD MARRY A MAN
WHO LOOKED LIKE RECRUITING
OFFICER.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT SINKING ABOUT
WOMEN'S MOTIVATION IS MY CENTRAL
CHARACTER WHO IS STILL ALIVE AND
GOING STRONG, REPRESENTS JUST
SORT OF HOW WRONG HEADED THAT
STRATEGY WAS.
LIKE MANY YOUNG AMERICAN WOMEN,
SHE WAS ENGAGED BUT UNWILLINGLY
SO, HER COLLEGE BOYFRIEND SENT
HER A RING FROM TRAINING CAMP IN
CALIFORNIA, WOMEN WERE TOLL NOT
TO UPSET MORALE OF THE TROOPS,
SHE DIDN'T WANT THE GET MARRIED,
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO MARRY OUT OF
COLLEGE, SHE LIKED THIS GUY BUT
DIDN'T ENVISION SPENDING HER
LIFE WITH HIM.
SHE WANTED AND AN EXCUSE NOT TO
HAVE
TO GET MARRIED AND GO TO THIS
TRAINING CAMP IN CALIFORNIA SO
PROS SPECK OF WAR WORK IN
WASHINGTON GAVE HER AN OUT FROM
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN HER FOUR OR
DANEED LIFE TRAJECTORY, IT GAVE
HER AN EXCUSE NOT TO GO TO
CALIFORNIA.
SHE WAS ALSO MOTIVATED BECAUSE
SHE WAS THE OLDEST DAUGHTER IN A
FAMILY OF FOUR, SHE HAD TWO
YOUNGER BROTHERS ALREADY IN THE
U.S. ARMY, ONE RIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL, LITERALLY THE DAY HE
GRADUATED SO LICK ALL AMERICAN
FAMILY SHE IS HAD A PERSONAL
INTEREST IN THE OUTCOME OF THE
WAR.
THE FAMILY WAS TYPICAL, THEY
WERE VOLUNTEERING EVERYTHING TO
THE WAR EFFORT.
PEOPLE WERE DONATES POTTS AND
PANS, PICKING UP RUBBER BANDS
FROM THE STREET.
THE FAMILY TRIED TO DONATE THEIR
FAMILY DOGTY TRAIN TO BECOME A
WAR DOG.
SHE STILL HAS A SINGLE SPACE
LETTER FROM THE ARMY WAR DOG
TRAINING CENTER SAYING THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTION OR FOR
YOUR OFFER, WE HAVE AN AGE CAP
ON OUR WAR DOGS AND SHE WAS TOO
OLD.
SO SHE HAD TO STAY HOME BUT
THAT'S HOW MOTIVATED PEOPLE WERE
TO JOIN THE WAR EFFORT.
SO DOT WAS ALSO IN HER FIRST
YEAR OF TEACHING AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL, ALL THE MALE TEACHERS
LEFT, MANY FEMALE TEACHERS HAD
LEFT TO MARRY THE MEN.
SO SHE WAS TEACHING ENGLISH,
FRENCH, LATIN, PHYSICS,
SOMETHING CALLED HYGIENE, SHE
WAS INCREDIBLY BURDENED BY THE
LOAD, SHE WAS MAKING $900 A
MONTH TEACHING SCHOOL IN
CHATHAM, SHE CAME HOME THE MOM
IN LYNCHBERG AND SAID I CAN'T DO
THAT ANY MORE.
THERE'S RECRUITERS IN THIS HOTEL
IN LYNCH BERK, SEE WHAT THEY
WANT.
>> DO SO WHEN SHE CAME THROUGH
THE DOOR SHE DIDN'T CARE IF THE
RECRUITER WAS GOOD LOOKING, SHE
KNEW IT WAS WAR WORK, IT WAS
IMPORTANT, LYNCH BESTING WAS
THREE HOURS FROM D.C, SHE HAD
NEVER BEEN THERE, SHE GREW UP
DURING THE DEPRESSION, NEVER
SEEN A BIG CITY, THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN WAR EFFORT
TO HELP HER BROTHERS AND TO MAKE
1,660-DOLLARS WORKING FOR THE
WAR DEPARTMENT, ALMOST TWICE
WHAT SHE MADE AT A TEACHER.
SO LIKE THOUSANDS OF OTHERS
SOUTHERN SCHOOLTEACHERS DOT GOT
ON THE TRAIN ONE MORNING AND
CAME TO WASHINGTON D.C. AND
FOUND HERSELF AT UNION STATION
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY IN
HER POCKET BOOK AND NO IDEA WHAT
SHE HAD SIGNED UP TO DO.
BECAUSE THIS RECRUITING
SCHOOLTEACHERS WAS TAKING PLACE
IN PUBLIC, THEY COULDN'T ETCH
TELL THE WOMEN WHAT THEY HAD
SIGNED UP FOR.
SHE TOOK A CAB TO ARLINGTON,
VIRGINIA AND FOUND HERSELF WHAT
HAD BEEN A JUNIOR COLLEGE AND
JUNIOR COLLEGES WERE A THING
BACK THEN, THEY WERE A WAY TO
GIVE WOMEN SOME EDUCATION
WITHOUT GIVING THEM TOO MUCH
EDUCATION SO THEY BASICALLY
AMENDED TO TWO YEARS OF HIGH
SCHOOL, TWO OF COLLEGEND, WOMEN
GET ENGLISH MATH, SOME FRENCH,
TYPING, HORSE BACK RIDING, THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT PREPARE
THEM FOR ADULTHOOD SO ARMY
NEEDED A BIG SECURE OFF THE
BEATEN PATH COMPOUND FOR CODE
BREAKING EFFORT SO IT KICKED THE
GIRLS OUT AND REQUISITIONED
ARLINGTON HALL, IT BUILDS
ENORMOUS TEMPORARY BUILDINGS
WHERE THE WRITING PATHS --
RIDING PATHS HAD BEEN AND IT
ROUTED THESE SOUTHERN
SCHOOLTEACHERS INTO THESE
MASSIVE HOT TEMPORARY BUILDINGS,
THERE WAS THE FIRST DAY IN
WASHINGTON DOT HAD NO IDEA WHAT
SHE WAS SIGNING UP TO DO BUT HAD
TO SIGN A LOYALTY OATH TO THE US
GOVERNMENT, SIGN A SECRECY OATH
AGREEING SHE WOULD NEVER TALK
ABOUT IT, IT WAS WARTIME,
PENALTY FOR REVEALING TOP SECRET
WORK WAS DEATH.
SO SHE KNEW THAT WHATEVER SHE
WAS GOING TO BE DOING SHE WOULD
BE SHOT IF SHE TOLD ANYBODY
ABOUT IT.
SO THAT WAS HER WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON.
ALL OF THE WOMEN WHO CAME TO DO
THIS WORK WOULD BE TOLD IF
ANYBODY ASKED THEM WHAT THEY
WERE DOING IN THESE COMPOUNDS
THEY WERE TO SAY THEY WERE
SECRETARIES.
THAT THEY SHARPEN PENCILS EMPTY
WASTE BASKET, UNIMPORTANT WORK.
SOME SAID THEY SAT ON THE LAPS
OF THEIR COMMANDING OFFICERS,
EVERYBODY BELIEVED THAT BECAUSE
THEY WERE WOMEN, THE WORK THEY
WERE DOING HAD TO BE TRIVIAL.
SO IN THAT WAY THEY WERE THE
IDEAL INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS OF
THE TIME BUT PEOPLE JUST ASSUMED
THAT WHATEVER THEY WERE DOING
INSIDE THESE TOP SECRET
COMPOUNDS, COULDN'T BE IMPORTANT
TO THE WAR EFFORT.
BUT INSTEAD, DOT JOINS
CLASSROOMS SCHOOLTEACHERS WERE
HASTE HI INSTRUCTED, IN THIS
CASE IN THE GEOGRAPHY OF ASIA,
THESE ARE WOMEN WHO WOULD BE
RECEIVING THE MESSAGES THAT WE
INTERCEPTED FROM THE PACIFIC, WE
WOULD ENCRYPT WITH OUR OWN
ENCRYPTION, SEND THEM TO
ARLINGTON HALL, WE STRIP OUT THE
AMERICAN ENCRYPTION AND THEN
SCHOOLTEACHERS LIKE DOT WOULD
GET STARTED ON MESSAGES.  THIS
IS THE ROOM DOT WOULD HAVE
WORKED IN, YOU CAN SEE ALL THESE
YOUNG WOMEN WORKING AT TABLES.
SHE STILL HAS A HARD TIME
BELIEVING THAT SHE HAD JOINED
WHAT WOULD BE THE THIRD OF THE
THREE MOST IMPORTANT CODE
BREAKING TRIUMPHS OF WORLD WAR
II.
ONE WAS BATTLE OF MIDWAY, ONE
WAS BREAKING ENIGMA CIPHER, THE
THIRD NOT AS MUCH ATTENTION
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A DRAMATIC
MOMENT WAS RELENTLESS SINKING OF
THE SHIP THAT WAS SUPPLYING THE
JAPANESE ARMY ALL AROUND THE
PACIFIC.
THE JAPANESE WERE ON ISLANDS FOR
THE MOST PART, THEY HAD TO BE
REGULARLY SUPPLIED WITH WATER,
WITH FOOD, WITH FUEL, WITH
MEDICINE, WITH SPARE AIRPLANE
PARTS, WITH REINFORCEMENT
TROOPS, ALL THAT WAS BROUGHT BY
SHIP, THOSE SHIPS WERE SENDING
MESSAGES EVERY DAY SAYING WHERE
THEY WERE COMING FROM, WHERE
THEY WERE GOING TO, IT WAS A
COMPLICATED SYSTEM CALLED AN
ENCIPHERED CODE SYSTEM, A WORLD
LIKE MORE ROW FOR SUPPLY SHIP IS
A FOUR DIGIT CODE GROUP, ANOTHER
WOULD BE ADDED TO THAT TO CHANGE
THE NUMBERS THAT WAS AN EARLY
FORM OF ENCRYPTION.
SENT MY MORSE CODE, WE SNATCH IT
OUT OF THE AIR, THE
SCHOOLTEACHERS WOULD STRIP OUT
THAT ENCRYPTION, STRIPPING OUT
THE EXTRANEOUS NUMBERS TO GET TO
CODE GROUP AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THEY MEANT.
BECAUSE THEY DID IT SO WELL AND
RAPIDLY, DOT REMEMBERS RUNNING
TO GET THE MESSAGES TO THE NEXT
STAGE, WE WERE ABLE TO SAVE
THOUSANDS OF SUPPLY SHIPS, THE
INFORMATION THE MESSAGES WOULD
BE SENT TO AMERICAN SUBMARINE
COMMANDERS WHO WOULD BE WAITING
WHEN THE SHIPS APPEARED, THEY
WERE RELENTLESSLY SUNK AND THE
RESULT WAS MOST JAPANESE A ARMY
DEATHS WERE RESULT OF STARVATION
AND DISEASE.
THAT'S HOW WELL THE
SCHOOLTEACHERS DID THEIR JOB.
DOT REMEMBERS SHE WOULD GET THE
MESSAGE FARCE AND TAKE IT TO THE
OVERLAPPER AND SHE WAS VERY
NERVOUS ABOUT SPEAKING THAT WORD
BECAUSE WOMEN WERE TOLL NEVER TO
UTTER CERTAIN WORDS ON THE
STREETS OF WASHINGTON, OVERLAP
WAS A TERM OF ART AND IF THEY
SPOKE IT ON THE STREET SOMEBODY
WOULD OVERHEAR SO WHEN I DID MY
INTERVIEW WITH HER, MANY
INTERVIEWS WITH HER, SHE HAD
NEVER USED THE WORD OVERLAPPER,
SHE FELT UNEASY SAYING IT EVEN
NOW.
WHAT SHE REMEMBERED, ONE OF MY
FAVORITE PARTS, THE OVERLAPPER
WAS A WOMAN NAMED MIRIAM FROM
NEW YORK CITY.
BECAUSE THERE WERE WOMEN
RECRUITED FROM NORTHERN COLLEGES
AS WELL.
AND DOT REMEMBERS MIRIAM BEING
THE MOST CONDESCENDING
NORTHERNER EVER MET AND I'M FROM
THE SAME PART OF VIRGINIA DOT IS
SO I SOMEWHAT IDENTIFY WITH THIS
PART OF THE STORY.
AND SHE RECALLED THAT MIRIAM
WOULD MAKE FUN OF HER SEWN
ACCENT AND IT'S -- SOUTHERN
ACCENT.
EVEN AS AMERICAN GIS WERE ALL
OVER THE WORLD, AT GREAT PEARL
AN RISK TO THEIR LIVES, THEIR
STAYING IN SOUTH PACIFIC AND
PARIS, THESE WOMEN WERE COMING
TOGETHER AND MANY WOMEN ARE FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY BUT
THEY WERE ALSO HAVING TO
FUNCTION WITH THEM IN A
WORKPLACE AND IT WAS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WORK BUT ALSO A
GOVERNMENT WORKPLACE.
AND MIRIAM GOT ON DOT'S NERVES.
BECAUSE THE WOMEN CLASHED, THEY
WERE DIFFERENT PARTS OF COUNTRY,
THE NORTHERNERS SEE THE SOUTHERN
WOMEN BEING LESS WELL EDUCATED,
ALSO MEN WORKING AT THE FACILITY
TOO OLD FOR FIGHTING SO THERE
WERE MANY DISTINGUISHED MEN FROM
PUBLISHKING CIRCLES WHO CAME
DOWN TO WORK IN THE CODE
BREAKING OPERATION AND ONE OF
THEM REFERRED TO SOUTHERN WOMEN
AS JEWELS BECAUSE HE FELT SO
MANY SOUTHERN WOMEN WERE NAMED O
PAL OR PEARL OR RUBY OR EMERALD.
I HAVE TO A MITT WHEN I WENT
THROUGH THE ROSTERS A T THE
ARCHIVES THERE WERE A LOT OF
WOMEN NAMED RUBY AND EMERALD AND
PEARL AND THEY WERE JEWELS, ONE
WOMAN I INTERVIEWED FOR THIS
BOOKER, JEWEL FROM SOUTH
CAROLINA WAS A GRADUATE OF
WINTHROP COLLEGE IN SOUTH
CAROLINA; SHE WAS A HIGH SCHOOL
BAND DIRECTOR WHEN RECRUITED AND
MUSICAL TALENT IS A MARK FOR
CODE BREAKING ABILITY BECAUSE IT
HAS THE ABILITY TO FOLLOW
PATTERNS SO I HAVE TO GRANT
THERE WERE A FAIR AMOUNT OF
SOUTHERN WOMEN WHO HAD JEWEL
LIKE NAMES.
I LOVE THIS PHOTO BECAUSE THE
WOMEN THAT YOU SEE LAUGHING DOWN
AT HER WORK SITTING NEXT TO THE
DEAD PLANT, SHE HAS BEEN
RECRUITED ADS ENGLISH MAJOR FROM
A COLLEGE OUTSIDE OF NEW YORK
AND SHE WORKING WITH A WEST
VIRGINIA SCHOOLTEACHER NAMED
WILMA, THEY BROKE A SEPARATE
CODE SYSTEM THAT APPENDED EVERY
JAPANESE ARMY MESSAGE, IT WAS
THE ADDRESS OF WHERE IT WAS
COMING TO, AND WHERE IT WAS
DESTINED FOR THE PERSON SENDING
IT, THE RANK OF THE PERSON
SENDING IT, THE PERSON RECEIVING
IT, THE RANK OF THAT PERSON.
VAST AM OF USEFUL INFORMATION
FOR OUR MILITARY TO HAVE BECAUSE
WE WANT KNOW WHERE JAPANESE ARE,
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO, WHO
THEY'RE COMMUNICATING WITH,
FLURRY OF MESSAGES, MAYBE
SOMETHING IS BEING PLANNED, SO
THANKS TO THEIR BREAKING OF THAT
PARTICULAR MESSAGE SYSTEM, WE
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
PENTAGON EVERY DAY WITH
SOMETHING CALLED ORDER OF BALLET
THAT SHOWED
BATTLE, WHERE NEW MESSAGES WERE
BEING SENT TO SO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT INTELLIGENCE, THE
WOMEN WAS GENERATING
INTELLIGENCE, THE PENTAGON WAS
BREATHING DOWN THEIR NECK TO GET
THIS REPORT EVERY DAY.
TO GIVE A SENSE HOW MANY CODE
ENSYVER SYSTEMS WERE IN PLAY,
THE JANUARY NEEDS DIP MATS
STATIONED IN EUROPE IN ALL THE
OCCUPIED COUNTRIES ALL THE THE
AXIS
COUNTRIES, THEY WERE TALKING TO
TOKYO IN A -- IT WAS A SCREEN
ROMANIZED JAPANESE INTO UN
UNINTELLIGIBLE GIBBERISH, WE HAD
BROKEN THAT MACHINE SYSTEM
BEFORE THE WAR THANKS TO A WOMAN
NAMED JENEVIEVE, WE WERE READING
ALL THOSE COMMUNICATIONS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT BITS WE GOT
FROM THE JAPANESE DIP MATS ABOUT
EUROPE WAS WHEN THEY WERE
INVITED TO TOUR THE COAST OF
FRANCE, BEFORE D DAY, THEY WERE
DUTIFULLY REPORTED BACK TO TOKYO
WHERE THE COST OF FRANCE WAS
FORTIFIED AND WHERE IT WASN'T SO
WE KNEW WHEN WE WERE PLANNING
THE ALLIED LANDING THAT NORMANDY
WOULD BE A BETTER PLACE TO LAND
THAN OTHER PARTS OF THE FRENCH
CODE SO THAT'S THE INFORMATION
WE WERE GETTING FROM THE CODE
BREAKING OPERATIONS.
THIS GIVES YOU SENSE OF THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN DOING THIS WORK.
THERE WAS ALSO AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN CODE BREAKING UNIT AT
ARLINGTON HALL, THE U.S. ARMY
WAS SEGREGATED DURING THE WORLD
WAR II SO THE CODE BREAKING
OPERATION WAS SEGREGATED AS
WELL, THIS WAS A SECRET UNIT, A
LOT OF WHITE WORKERS DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT BUT THIS GROUP OF WELL
EDUCATED VERY DEDICATED PROBABLY
FORMER SCHOOLTEACHERS WHO ATTAIN
THEIR EDUCATION IN A SEGREGATED
U.S. EDUCATION SYSTEM, LENDING
THEIR TALENTS TO BREAKING THE
CODES AND CIPHERS OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
SO JUST AS BANKS AND COMPANIES
ENCRYPT FINANCIAL COMMUNICATION
WHEN THEY SEND IT OVER THE
INTERNET, SO TOO WHEN ARE THEY
DOING THAT BACK THEN, THIS YOU
WANTIA WAS READING THE CODES AND
CIPHERS OF BANKS AND COMPANIES
TO SEE WHO WAS DOING BUSINESS
WITH HITLER, WHO WAS DOING
BUSINESS WITH JAPANESE COMPANIES
LIKES MITSUBISHI, BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
THAT SO THIS WAS VERY IMPORTANT
WORK AND VERY UNSUNG UNIT.
THEY WERE ALSO DOING EARLY CYBER
SECURITY LOOKING FOR IS TO MAKE
SURE OUR EPICRIPPED TRAFFIC THAT
WE WERE -- P ENCRYPTED TRAFFIC
WAS MORE SKEWER THAN THE CODE.
SUBPOENAS WE WERE READING.
ALSO PLANNING DECEPTION PROGRAMS
CALLED DUMB MY TRAFFIC TO
PERSUADE THE ENEMY BECAUSE OF
THE THE SIGNALS WE WERE SENDING
PERSUADE THE ENEMY WE HAD
STATIONS WHERE NONE EXISTED.
BEFORE THE D DAY LANDINGS, THIS
DUMMY TRAFFIC PERSUADED GERMANS
THE ALLYIED TROOPS WAS GOING TO
LAND IN CAAY.
SO MEANTIME THIS IS THE TIPPING
POINT, REALLY FIRST MAJOR
EXPERIMENT WITH ADMITTING WOMEN
INTO THE MILITARY AND THE
DECISION WAS MADE IN 1942 TO
ADMIT WOMEN INTO THE ARMY, AND
ALSO TO ADMIT WOMEN INTO THE
NAVY, IT WAS A HARD FOUGHT
BATTLE, MANY DEANS AND PROFESSOR
AS T THE WOMEN COLLEGES REALLY
PRESSED THE NAVY TO ADMIT YOUNG
WOMEN, THEY SAW THIS AS A
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
GRADUATES, SO THE WOMEN WHO CAME
TO WASHINGTON YOU SAW THEM IN
THIS REALLY -- FRILLY DRESSES AT
THE BEGINNING, THEY ALLOT ITALY
-- THEY WANTED FEMALE CODE
BREAKERS TO BE SUBJECT TO
MILITARY DISCIPLINE AND
HIERARCHY SO THEY WERE TRAINED
TO BECOME NAVAL OFFICERS.
SO YOU CAN SEE THEM HERE,
ACTUALLY CROSSING NEBRASKA
AVENUE, THE NAVY ALSO GAVE MORE
SPACE THAN IT HAD DOWNTOWN SO IT
COMMANDEERED SEMINARY ON
NEBRASKA AVENUE WHERE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY IS NOW.
KICKED THOSE GIRLS OUT, THE
GIRLS HAD TO TAKE CLASSES AT A
DEPARTMENT STORE WHILE FINDING A
PLACE TO STUDY.
THEY SET UP A MASSIVE CODE
BREAKING OPERATION, THE WOMEN
WERE HELD IN BARRACKS NEAR
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY YOU CAN SEE
THEM CROSSING THE STREET.
THIS IS A GREAT MOMENT FOR WOMEN
TO JOIN MILITARY, ALSO A MOMENT
WHEN WOMEN WHO DIDN'T HAVE
COLLEGE EDUCATION COULD ENLIST
AS ORDINARY SEAMEN, WHEN THEY
TOOK THE APTITUDE TESTS IF
TESTED HIGH FOR ABILITY AND THE
RIGHT INTELLECTUAL SKILLS LIKE
MATH AND LANGUAGE, THEY WOULD BE
SECRETLY ROUTED TO THE CODE
BREAKING OPERATION SO THIS WAS A
GREAT COMING TOGETHER OF WOMEN
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, WOMEN
FROM COLORADO, NAVY LOOKING FOR
LIBRARIAN, PEOPLE WHO KNEW HOW
TO KEEP GREAT RECORDS, THEY CAME
FROM COLORADO, OKLAHOMA,
CALIFORNIA, THEY GOT ON TRAINS
AND TRAVELED FOR DAYS, WENT TO
BOOT CAMP AND OFFICER TRAINING
CAMP AND THEY CAME TOGETHER
THOUSANDS OF WOMEN WORKING AT
THESE COMPOUNDS, ONE OF MY
FAVORITE ANECDOTES ABOUT COMING
TOGETHER OF THESE WOMEN, ONE
WOMAN I INTERVIEWED FOR THIS
BOOK, JANE KATE ACTUALLY CAME
FROM AFFLUENT FAMILY IN NEW YORK
CITY, SHE GREW UP IN AUBURN, NEW
YORK AND ON THE UPPER EAST SIDE
OF THE NEW YORK CITY, A VERY
SORT OF DEBUTANTE KIND OF
SOCIETY SHE WAS EXPECTING TO
HAVE TO BE PART OF.
WHEN THE WAR STARTED SHE WANTED
TO DO WHAT SHE COULD.
SHE DESPERATELY WANTEDDED TO
ENLIST IN THE U.S. NAVY, HER
PARENTS DIDN'T WANT HER TO,
THERE WAS STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE WOMEN, THEY WERE
CONSIDERED TO BE BAD WOMEN,
THERE WERE WHISPER CAMPAIGNS
AGAINST THEM, THINKING WAS THEY
WERE PUT IN THE MILITARY TO
SERVICE THE MEN SEXUALLY SO SOME
PARENTS DIDN'T WANT DAUGHTER
JOINING UP BUT SHE WAS
DETERMINED SO SHE TO BE THE
SUBWAY TO WALL STREET WHERE
THERE WAS A RECRUITING STATION,
SHE EXPECTED TO GO IN AS OFFICER
BECAUSE SHE CAME FROM UPPER
CLASS FAMILY AND SHE KNEW SHE
HAD TO PASS AN EYE EXAM SO SHE
-- SHE WAS VERY, VERY
NEARSIGHTED.
SHE MEMORIZED THE EYE CHART IN
ORDER TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE EYE
EXAM, SHE SLIPPED THE SPECTACLES
IN IN HER POCKET.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW THEY WERE GOING
TO BE OTHER MEDICAL STATIONS
INCLUDING A GYNECOLOGICAL EXAM
WHICH WAS A SHOCK FOR A LOT OF
THE WOMEN.
BUT THERE WAS ALSO A PHYSICAL
EXAM AND MEN AT THE TIME WERE
FORCED TO UNDERGO A GROUP NAKED
PHYSICAL TO JOIN THE NAVY.
THE NAVY WAS TRY TO FIGURE OUT
IF THEY SHOULD DO THE SAME FOR
WOMEN AS MEN SO THEY HAD A GROUP
-- JANE REMEMBERS THE SHOCK AT
BEING TOLL TO DISROBE.
THE PETTY OFFICER PUT A NINE ON
HER BREAST AND SHE SAID GO STAND
NEXT TO 8 AND 10.
BECAUSE SHE WAS SO NEAR
SIGHINGED WED HAD TO REALLY PEER
IN ORDER TO FIGURE WHERE SHE WAS
SUPPOSED TO STAND SO SHE
REMEMBERS THAT FONDLY.
AND SORT OF YOU'RE IN THE NAVY
NOW.
AND THIS WAS SOMETHING QUITE
DIFFERENT THAN THE DEBUTANTE
SOCIETY SHE WAS RAIDED TO.
WHEN SHE -- SHE ALSO FOUND THAT
SHE HAD GONE TO MUSIC SCHOOL
AFTER GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL, THE NAVY DIDN'T CONSIDER
THAT EQUIVALENT OF TWO YEARS OF
COLLEGE SO SHE WENT IN AS
ORDINARY SEAMAN, SHE WENT ADS
ENLISTED WOMAN AND BECAUSE OF
HER ABILITY WITH MATH, HER DAD
WAS A PHYSICIST AND BECAUSE OF
HER CHOP SHE WAS ROUTED TO THE
CODE BREAKING OPERATION AS WELL
ANDS LOVED I.
HER FIRST -- LOVED IT.
HER ROOMMATE WAS FROM THE
MIDWEST AND SO THAT WAS JANE'S
INTRODUCTION TO OTHER AMERICAN
DECORATING SCHEMES SHE HAD NOT
GROWN UP WITH.
SO THE NAVY WOMEN WORKED AT THIS
HUGE COMPOUND, I FOUND THESE
PHOTOGRAPHS IN THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES, JUST SWIMMING AROUND
AND FILES YOU CAN SEE I HAD TO
GET IT DECLASSIFIED BUT
WONDERFUL PHOTO TOES OF THE
ENTERER -- PHOTOS OF THE
INTERIOR OF THE CODE BREAKING
JUNE.
THEY HAVE WORKING THE JAPANESE
NAVAL FLEET CODE.
YOU CAN SEE MASSIVE SETS OF
JAPANESE MESSAGES JANE REMEMBERS
WE CAN TELL WHAT WAS HAPPENING
IN THE PACIFIC BECAUSE THE STAFF
WOULD GET LARGER.
THEY HAD THE PUSH THEM ALONG AS
FAST AS THEY CAN.
THEY HAD TO STRIP OUT NUMERICAL
AND CIPHER CALLED ADDITIVES TO
GET TO TO THE CODE GROUPS.
THEY WERE UNDER INCREDIBLE
PRESSURE, THEY WERE SOMETIMES
BREAKS MESSAGES THAT TOLD
LOCATION AND WHEREABOUTS OF
BROTHERS AND BOYFRIENDS SHIPS
THEY KNEW THE STATION.
I STAKES.
I FOUND MEMOS WHICH OFFICERS
WOULD SAY Y'ALL RECOVERED 2,000
ADDITIVES LAST MONTH WE NEED
MORE THIS MONTH.
WE'RE PLANNING TO PUSH BACK
ACROSS THE PACIFIC, WE WANT TO
RETAKE THE PHILIPPINE, THIS WORK
IS INC ABLY IMPORTANT.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHERE THE ENEMY
IS.
SO WE NEED YOU ALL TO WORK
HARDER AND FASTER AND I SEE MEMO
CONGRATULATING THEM FOR MEETING
THE QUOTA AND EXCEEDING IT.
SO THIS IS ONE OF THE WORK
SHEETS THE JAPANESE NAVAL FLEET
CODE WAS A FIVE DIGIT ENSYVERRED
CODE SYSTEM.
I LOVE THESE WORK SHEETS,
THEY'RE SWIMMING IN FILES NOR
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES BUT THEY
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE BRAIN
WORK THE WOMEN HAD THE DO TO
RECOVER THESE ADDITIVES.
I ALSO THIS TABLE, AGAIN IT
SHOWS YOU HOW MANY DIFFERENT
CODE SYSTEMS THERE WERE, THIS
WAS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SYSTEM, IT WAS A LESSER SYSTEM,
THAT THE JAPANESE NAVY AD HOC
SYSTEM, THEY SET UP, COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT, IT WAS LETTER, NOT
NUMBERS.
THERE WAS A GROUP OF WOMEN FROM
WELLSLY WHO WERE ASSIGNED TO
WORK THE INTERISLAND CIPHER, IT
HAD A KEY THAT CHANGE EVERY
MONTH AND THEY HAD TO BREAK THAT
INTO THE SYSTEM, THEY HAD TO
DETERMINE THE NEW KEY THAT WAS
BEING USED, TO THE CONTROL THE
SYSTEM EVERY MONTH.
AND THEY GOT SO GOOD AT THAT, I
GOT RECORDS HOW GOOD THEY WERE,
THEY CAN WORK HARD FOUR OR FIVE
DAY AND GO AUTO PILOT THE REST
OF THE MONTH.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THESE WOMEN
WERE LIVING UNCHAPERONED FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THEIR LIVES.
THERE WAS A LOT OF ALCOHOL IN
WASHINGTON DURING THE WORLD WAR
II AND IF THE WOMEN WERE NAVAL
OFFICERS THEY COULD LIVE IF
GROUP HOUSE, NOT BARRACKS SO
THEY COULD HAVE PARTIES AND THE
WOMEN HAD BIG BLOW OUTS.
I FOUND AN ORAL HISTORY OF THEIR
COMMANDING OFFICER WHO VERY MUCH
ADMIRED THEIR INTELLIGENCE BUT
ALSO ADMIRED THEIR PARTYING
SPIRITS.
HE REMEMBERED ONE OF THE
MATHEMATICIANS IN PARTICULAR A
MATH MAJOR COME AND ASK WHEN SHE
COULD HAVE HER NEXT BIG PARTY,
HE WOULD LOOK AT THE MAP AND SAY
THE KEY WILL CHANGE THE X DAY OF
THE MONTH, YOU CAN HAVE THE
PARTY TWO DAYS BEFORE THAT
BECAUSE YOU CAN RECOVER FROM
HANG OVERS FOR TWO WEEKS BEFORE
YOU APPLY INTELLECT.
BUT A SENSE OF THE STATION IN
APRIL OF 1942 WE RECEIVED
MESSAGES IN THE PACIFIC SAYING
ADMIRAL YAMOMOMOTO WHO COMMANDED
THE JAPANESE FLEET AND MASTER
MIND OF PEARL HARBOR WOULD BE
MAKING INSPECTION TOWARD THE SOL
MAN ISLANDS, THE CIPHER WAS PART
OF THIS SET OF COMMUNICATIONS.
MANY IN THE PACIFIC, AMERICAN
MEN IN THE PACIFIC GOT PIZZA ON
THE FLEET CODE MESSAGES, THESE
WOMEN GOT BUSY ON THE
INTERISLAND CIPHER, PUT EXACT
SIGH TEN RARE DOWN TO THE MINUTE
SO WE COULD SEND PLANES UP AND
SHOOT HIM AND MADE THE DECISION
TO ASSASSINATE AN ENEMY
COMMANDER AND THE WOMEN
REMEMBERING THAT CHEERING WENT
UP IN THE NAVAL CODE BREAKING
COMPOUND WHEN THEY KNEW THE
PLANE WAS SHOT DOWN.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND THE
JAPANESE COULDN'T KNOW THAT IT
HAPPENED AS A RESULT OF CODE
BREAKING BUT THE WOMEN KNEW.
IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK TO POINT
OUT THEY FELT GREAT SATISFACTION
AT THE TIME WHEN THEY NEEDED
THEIR WORK HAD CONTRIBUTED TO
THE SINKING OF A CONVOY OR FLEET
OR TO THE DOWNING OF AN
IMPORTANT AIRPLANE.
IT WAS WAR, WE WANTED TO WIN IT.
THEY DIDN'T RENEW LIVES WERE AT
STAKE, BROTHERS AND BOYFRIEND,
THEY KNEW AMERICA WAS AT STAKE
AND FREEDOM SO THEY WANTED TO
WIN AND WANTED TO DO WHAT HAD TO
BE DONE.
LATER IN LIVES THEY WOULD HAVE
MORE COMPLEX FEELINGS ABOUT THE
LETHAL WORK THAT THEY WERE PART
OF.
BUT AT THE TIME THERE WERE NO
SECOND THOUGHTS.
SO JUST TO QUICKLY POINT OUT, WE
EVENTUALLY BECAME THE SENIOR
PARTNER IN THE BREAKING OF THE
ENIGMA CIPHER THAT WAS USING TO
COMMAND U BOATS.
THE GERMANS SUSPECTED THAT WE
WERE READING THEIR CODE SYSTEM,
THEY CHANGED THE MACHINE THAT
WAS BEING USED BY THE U BOATS,
ADDED AN EXTRA ROTOR THAT
SCRAMBLED THE MESSAGES MORE THAN
BEFORE SO THE AMERICAN
INDUSTRIAL RESOURCES HAD TO GET
INVOLVED TO BUILD THESE GIANT
MACHINES THAT COULD HANDLE A
FOUR ROTOR MACHINE, THE OLE ONE
WAS THREE ROTORS AND WE NEEDED
MORE HEAVY DUTY FASTER MACHINES
SO THE AMERICANS DESIGNED AND
BUILT THESE MACHINES THAT WERE
SECRETLY TRANSPORTED AGAIN TO
THE NAVAL CODE BREAKING
COMPOUND.
FOR ME ONE OF THE MOST MOVING
AND REALLY WOMEN WORKING THE
GERMAN ENIGMA CIPHER SYSTEM AND
IT INVOLVED MATH, DESIGNING
EARLY COMPUTER MENUS IN ORDER TO
BREAK INTO THOSE MESSAGES.
ONE OF THE MOVING CHAPTERS TO ME
OF THE BOOK IS WHEN THE WOMEN
JOINED THE MIDNIGHT WATCH ON THE
NIGHT OF JUNE 6, EARLY MORNING
JUNE 5 AND INTO JUNE 6.
THEY KNEW THE LANDINGS WERE
GOING TO P HA, THEY DIDN'T KNOW
WHEN, IT WAS A FULL MOON, THEY
ASSUMED THAT WAS NOT IDEAL FOR A
SECRET ALLIED LANDING SO THEY
THOUGHT IT WASN'T GOING THE
HAPPEN ON THE 6TH.
BUT THEY REMEMBER THAT ABOUT
1:30 IN THE MORNING OUR TIME
THEY STARTED GETTING MESSAGES
THE MACHINES STARTED SPINNING.
THE GERMANS STARTED CHATTERING
AND THEY WERE EXPERIENCING THESE
WOMEN WERE EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCINGS THE D
DAY LANDINGS FROM THE GERMANS
AND THE FIRST MESSAGES WERE
GERMAN OFFICERS SAYING SEEING
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
ALLIED SHIP ONS HORIZON SAYING
MY GOD THE LANDING IS HAPPENING
AND IT'S HAPPENING IN NORMANDY.
SO THE WOMEN REMEMBERED WORK
FAST AS THEY COULD TO BREAK THE
GERMAN MESSAGES SO I WERE THAT
IN THE UNIQUE EXPERIENCE OF --
COMMUNICATING WHAT WAS GOING ON
SO THE KNEW THE LANDINGS WERE
HAPPENING, THEY HAD BROTHER AND
BOYFRIENDS MAKING THE LANDING.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW IT WAS
GOING, THEY COULDN'T TELL FROM
THE GERMAN MESSAGE, EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE D DAY INVASION SO THEY
WERE OVERWHELMEDDED BY THE E
NORTY OF WHAT THEY WERE PART OF.
AT THE END OF THE SHIFT THEY
REMEMBER TAKING THE BUS TO
NATIONAL CATHEDRAL AND GOING TO
SAINT AL BANS CHAPEL OPEN 24/7
DURING THE WAR AND PRAYING
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THE OUTCOME WAS, THEY DIDN'T
KNOW HOW MANY LIVES WERE LOST
AND A NUMBER HAD IN FACT LOST
THEIR FIANCES IN THE INVASION,
THEY DIDN'T KNOW IT YET BECAUSE
THEY HADN'T GOTTEN THE TELEGRAM.
HERE IS MY TOES OF CENTRAL
CHARACTER, DOT AT THE POLL, THEY
WERE DOING SERIOUS URGENT
STRESSFUL WORK THEY WERE HAVING
A GOOD TIME IN WASHINGTON
WRITING LOTS OF MEN MY CENTRAL
CHARGE WAS WRITING HALF A DOZEN
MEN, SHE WAS SOME WAYS MORE
RELUCTANT TO CONFESS THAT TO ME
THAN TALKING ABOUT THE SECRET
CODE BREAKING WORK.
SHE DISENTANGLED HERSELF FROM
ENGAGEMENT AND MARRIED ONE OF
THE MEN THAT SHE WAS WRITING
TOO, HAD A VERY HAPPY MARRIAGE,
BECAME BEST FRIENDS WITH A
SCHOOLTEACHER FROM MISSISSIPPI,
RUTH, AN INCREDIBLE
MATHEMATICIAN, WHO WENT TO WORK
FOR THE NSA.
THE WOMEN REMAINED BEST FRIENDS
FOR THEIR LIVES UM YOU CAN SEE
THEM WITH THEIR HUSBANDS.
THEY WERE SUCH CLOSE FRIENDS
AFTER THE WAR THEY COULD NEVER
TALK TO EACH OTHER ABOUT CODE
BREAKING WORK, THEY DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THEY WERE PART OF THE SAME
CODE BREAKING EFFORT TO BREAK
THE SUPPLY SHIPS.
THEY WERE TERRIFIED OF TALKING
ABOUT THEIR WORK EITHER BEFORE
OR AFTER THE WAR.
ALL THESE WOMEN WERE TOLD AT END
OF THE WAR THANKS FOR YOUR
EFFORTS, YOU U SAVED THOUSANDS
OF LIVES YOU SHORTENED THE WAR
BY A YEAR, NOW NEVER TELL
ANYBODY WHAT YOU DID.
SO THEY WENT INTO LATER LIFE
NEVER TALKING ABOUT THIS WORK,
DOT'S BROTHERS BOTH SURVIVED THE
WAR, BOTH HER BROTHERS WOULD
TAKE JOBS AT TOP SECRET SECURITY
CLEARANCE, THEY WOULD BRAC ABOUT
THE SECURITY CLEARANCE, DOT
COULD NEVER TELL THEM ABOUT THE
SECURITY CLEARANCE SO THEY HAD
TO PUT UP WITH THAT FOR DECADES.
BUT THEY REMAINED SO CLOSE FOR A
LISTENING TIME CHILDREN THOUGHT
THEY WERE RELATED TO EACH OTHER
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THESE TWO
WOMEN SHARED GREAT FRIENDSHIP AS
WELL AS SOME SECRET WHAT THEY
HAD DONE DURING THE WAR.
THISES A GROUP OF NAVAL ENLISTED
WOMEN WHO ALSO REMAINED GREAT
FRIENDS AFTER THE WAR WAS OVER.
ONLY ONE OF THEM IS STILL ALIVE.
RUTH WHO YOU CAN SEE IN THE
STRIPED SHIRT.
I AM HE RECOLLECTS EMAIL WHEN
SHE COMMUNICATES WITH ME IS RUTH
THE WAVE.
AT 95 SHE'S ON EMAIL BECAUSE
THEY WERE CODE GIRLS THEN AND
THEY'RE CODE GIRLS NOW.
THIS WORK THOUGH THEY COULDN'T
TALK ABOUT IT FOR 75 YEARS,
REMAINS SO IMPORTANT TO THEM,
THEM,
THAT THAT -- SHE CHOSE THAT AS
HER EMAILING ADDRESS.
I WANTED TO END WITH A COUPLE OF
QUICK VIDEOS THAT GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE WOMEN, TALKING
ABOUT THEIR WORK, WHAT WAS
IMPORTANT TO THEM, AND
REMEMBERING SOME OTHER MOST
MEMORABLE EXPERIENCES.
SO THIS IS DOT.
>> MY UMBRELLA AND MY RAINCOAT,
U WENT DOWN TO THE TRAIN NEAR MY
UNCLE HAD TO TAKE ME DOWN THERE.
NO CAR.
AND MY MOTHER AND HER SISTER
WERE STANDING THERE CRYING WHEN
I GOT ON THE TRAIN.
I WAS VERY SECURE THAT
EVERYTHING WAS GOING TO BE JUST
THAT.
WASHINGTON WOULD RECEIVE ME WITH
OPEN ARMS.
>> OF COURSE THE MESSAGE SHE GOT
IN WASHINGTON IS SHE WOULD BE
SHOT IF SHE TOLL ANYBODY WHAT
SHE WAS DOING.
SO THE NEXT WOMAN, ANN WAS
RECRUITED OUT OF SMITH COLLEGE
IN 1942, SHE WOULD WORK THE
JAPANESE NAVAL FLEET CODE.
>> SOMETHING YOU ASKED, YOU ADD
IT TO A FIVE DIGIT CODE GROUP.
AND THE CODE GROUP HAS A MEANING
WHICH IS EITHER A WORD OR A
PHRASE OR A SENTENCE OR A ROMAN
LETTER BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING
IN
JAPANESE WHO DIDN'T MAKE MUCH
USE OF ROMAN LETTERS BUT THEY
OFTEN DID SPELL NAMES.
>> SO HER MEMORY WAS SO SHARPED
SHE NEVER TALKED ABOUT THIS IN
75 YEARS AND SHE REMEMBERED
JAPANESE HAD A DIFFERENT CODE
GROUP OF EVERY LETTER OF THE
NAME ROOSEVELT BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT NOT HAVE A CHARACTER THAT
STOOD FOR ROOSEVELT.
SO HER MEMORY SO SO SHARP, SHE
SHOW ME THE MATH SHE HAD TO DO
TO RECOVER THE ADDITIVES.
SHE GOT IRRITATED WHEN I WAS
SLOW ON THE UPTAKE.
SO BECAUSE I WAS SAYING IF THEY
-- SO DID YOU SUBTRACT OR ADD?
AND SHE SAID WE GENERALIZE AND
ADD, HOW HARD IS THAT?
I LOVE HOW PRESIZE HER MEMORY
WAS OF THIS WORK SHE HAD NEVER
TOLD ANYBODY ABOUT.
THE NEXT WOMAN, BETTY WORKED
THOSE -- HELPED BUILD MACHINES
THAT BROKE THE GERMAN ENIGMA
CIPHER AND REMEMBERS BASICALLY
THE THANKS THEY GOT FOR THE
GREAT WORK THEY DID.
>> WE BROKE THE CODE IN AUGUST
OF 1943.
AND EVERYBODY SAYS WHAT DID THEY
TELL YOU?
I SAID NOTHING.
ALL THAT COMMANDER -- GOOD JOB,
GIRLS.
YOU DID GOOD.
FROM AND THAT'S ALL THEY SAID.
>> AND THE LAST WOMAN, DOROTHY,
YOU SAW HER PHOTO, RECRUITED
FROM INDIANA STATE TEACHERS
COLLEGE AND SHE REMEMBERS WHY IT
WAS SO IMPORTANT TO THE WOMEN TO
DO THIS WORK WHEN THEY WERE
RECRUITED.
>> OUR BUS CAME AND IT WAS AT
TWO O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
TO
GET THESE -- SEEMED TO ME IT WAS
ALL THERE THERE WERE NO LEFT,
THEY ALL HAD TO
GO I THINK TO
PITTSBURG.
I WAS
-- SO GOING ON THAT
BUS.
>> SOTOR THINK RAMALI WAS SUCH A
SUCCESSFUL CODE BREAKER THAT THE
U.S. NAVY STOLE HER FROM THE
IARMY.
SHE WAS THAT GOOD.
AND WHAT I LOVE ABOUT HER IS
THAT SHE BECAME A MATH TEACHER
AFTER THE WAR, SHE NEVER TOLD
ANYBODY WHAT SHE DID.
SHE WOULD END UP TEACHING AT THE
PUBLIC MIDDLE SCHOOL IN
ARLINGTON, VIRGINIA, THAT MY OWN
CHILDREN WOULD ULTIMATELY
ATTEND, AND THEN YORK TOWN HIGH
SCHOOL, I LOVE THE THOUGHT OF
THESE MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS TAKING
MS. RAMALI'S ALGEBRA 1 CLASS AND
HAVING NO IDEA THIS SWEET WOMAN
WHO PEOPLE REMEMBER AS
INCREDIBLE MATH TEACHER HAD BEEN
SUCH A BAD AS CODE BREAKER
DURING WORLD WAR II.
SHE NEVER TALKED ABOUT IT UNTIL
I INTERVIEWED HER.
AND SHE'S ALSO AN EXAMPLE OF THE
FACT THESE WOMEN WALKED AMONG US
FOR DECADES AND IN MANY CASES
STILL WALK AMONG US, THEY NEVER
EXPECTED CREDIT FOR WHAT THEY
DID.
MOST CASES THEY NEVER GOT ANY
CREDIT FOR WHAT THEY DID.
THEY TOOK THE SECRET TO THEIR
GRAVES.
I FELT VERY FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE
TO FIND 20 WOMEN LIVE WOMEN WHO
COULD TALK ABOUT THEIR WORK.
YOU SEE HOW EXCELLENT THEIR
MEMORIES WERE AN TO BE ABLE TO
TRY AND GET THEM SOME CREDIT FOR
THE INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTION THEY
MADE TO WINNING THE WAR AND TO
AMERICAN FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT.
AND AGAIN NEVER EXPECTING
CREDIT.
BY THE TIME I WAS INTERVIEWING
THEM, THEY KNEW THAT THEY HAD
LEFT OUT OF HISTORY.
THEY KNEW BOOKS WRITTEN ABOUT
PACIFIC CODE BREAKING AND
ATLANTIC CODE BREAKING HAD
PRETTY MUCH NOT TOLD THEIR STORY
BECAUSE THE WOMEN HAD BEEN SO
GOOD ABOUT NOT SPEAKING UP AND
ONE OF THE WOMEN I INTERVIEWED
IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM IN ATLANTA
BECAUSE SHE HAD BROKEN HER WRIST
THE NIGHT BEFORE, I LEARNED
EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE GOOD PLACES
TO INTERVIEW BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
WAIT A LONG TIME AND THEY CAN'T
-- THE PERSON CAN'T GO ANYWHERE.
BUT SHE SAID THAT I JUST HOPE
THAT I LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO SEE
THE BOOK
PUBLISHED.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY SHE DID.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING.
BEEN AN HONOR TO WORK WITH THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS AND TELL THE
STORY.
[APPLAUSE]
I THINK WE HAVE TIME FOR A FEW
QUESTIONS.
>> THANK YOU, LIZA FOR BRINGING
TO LIGHT THE STORIES OF THESE
INCREDIBLE WOMEN AN
CONTRIBUTIONS THEY MADE TO THE
COURSE OF WAR, TECHNOLOGY, CODE
BREAKING AND CYBER SECURITY.
BECAUSE OF YOUR WORK USING
PRIMARY SOURCES LIKE THOSE AT
THE VETERANNEN HISTORY PRO--
VETERANS HISTORY PROJECT,
STORIES LIKE THESE CANNOT BE
IGNORED.
THEY WILL BE INCLUDED IN ANNULS
OF HISTORY.
WE WERE THINKING HOW GREAT IT
WOULD BE TO HAVE THE CODE GIRLS
WITH US TODAY BUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GENERALLY IN THEIR 90s
AND A BIT FRAIL, WE THOUGHT
LET'S GIVE NEXT BEST THING AND
LIZA HELPED US REACH OUT TO
THOSE FAMILIES AND GET SOME OF
THOSE COLLECTIONS WE DIDN'T HAVE
IN OUR ARCHIVES HERE.
AND IN FEBRUARY WE RECEIVED A PA
CONTACT CONTAINING ORAL HISTORY
-- PACKAGE CONTAINING ORAL
HISTORY INTERVIEW, PHOTOGRAPH
AND MEMOIR WRITTEN BY ELIZABETH
BENNETT.
HER SON WHEN HE FOUND OUT WHAT
WE WERE DOING RALLIED HIS FAMILY
TO COLLECT THESE ITEMS AND SEND
THEM TO US RIGHT AWAY.
AND ONE OF THE EMAILS HE SENT TO
OUR STAFF, HE WROTE MY MOTHER IS
STILL ALIVE BUT HER HEALTH HAS
BEEN POOR OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS, OUR FAMILY IS VERY
GRATEFUL TO LIZA FOR HER BOOK
FEATURE IT IS CODE GIRLS AND YOU
AND THE VETERANS HISTORY PROJECT
FOR PRESERVING THE STORY OF
THESE REMARKABLE WOMEN.
FROMI'M SAD TO REPORT
MS. BENNETT BASS TON 16th OF
MARCH AT THE RIPE AGE OF 96.
I COULD SUGGEST CHEVIED A GOOD
LIFE.
I UNDERSTAND HER FAMILY IS
WATCHING LIVE ON YOUTUBE AND HER
SON DOUG FLU IN FROM
INDIANAPOLIS TO BE WITH US
TODAY.
-- FLEW IN FROM INDIANAPOLIS
TODAY TO BE WITH US.
SO THANK YOU, DOUG.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I WANT THEM TO UNDERSTAND HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE TO MAKE SURE
THEIR MOM'S STORY WILL LIVE ON
IN
PERPETUITY IN THIS LIBRARY.
IN CLOSING IF YOU ARE LIKE THE
BENNETTS AND HAVE A VETERAN IN
YOUR LIFE LIVING OR DECEASED, NO
MATTER BRANCH SERVICE OR
MILITARY CONSIGN.
, PLEASE CONSIDER DONATING THEIR
STORY TO THE VETERAN HISTORY
PROJECT.
WE HAVE A TABLE SET UP OUTSIDE
WHERE YOU CAN GET OUR FIELD KIT,
GO TO OUR WEBSITE AND HEAR
AMAZING STORIES.
AND THIS WAY YOU CAN PRESERVE
YOU CAN ENSURE A LOVED ONE'S
STORY WILL BE PRESERVED AND NOT
LOST OR FORGOTTEN.
SO AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US TODAY AND NOW WE HAVE SOME
TIME FOR QUESTIONS FOR -- WITH
YOU AND WITH LIZA.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADIEU.
(OFF MIC)
>> DID ANY OF THE WOMEN DEMAND
PROOF THAT IT WAS UNCLASSIFIED
THAT THEY COULD TALK ABOUT IT OR
DID THEY JUST BELIEVE YOU?
>> IT DID TAKE PERSUASION, IT
TOOK A HALF HOUR TO PERSUADE DOT
SHE WOULDN'T BE PUT IN PRISON IF
SHE SPOKE.
I TOLD HER IF SHE WAS IT WOULD
BE A NICE PRISON AT HER AGE.
SOME DID TAKE SOME COAXING.
AND I WILL SAY THEY HAD BEEN
RELEASED FROM THEIR RECEIVE OATH
OF SECRECY IN THE '90s BUT
NOBODY TOLD THEM.
SO THEY WERE FREE TO SPEAK.
>> YES.
YOUR PICTURES OF THE CROSSING ON
WISCONSIN AVENUE, A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT SOME PHOTOGRAPHS IN
THE D DOT COLLECTION AND THE
FIRST DON'T WALK PEDESTRIAN
SIGNALS WERE INSTALLED IN THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA AT THE
SIGHT.
I GUESS THEY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF THESE WOMEN.
>> YES.
AND THEY WERE ALSO SOME
NEIGHBORS WHO COMPLAINED ABOUT
NOISE AND SINGING AS WELL AS
NECKING IN THE WOODS.
>> 1965 I WAS SENT TO THE ARMY
TO FORT MEAD AND NSA FOR EIGHT
WEEK TRAINING IN CRYPTOGRAPHY.
SIX OF US, WE WALKED INTO
TRAINING THAT DAY AND WE WERE
TOTALLY SURROUNDED BY WOMEN.
AND I'M WONDERING IF NSA IS LIKE
THAT TODAY.
AND IF THERE WERE STUDIES THAT
WOMEN ARE BETTER WIRED FOR THIS
TYPE OF WORK?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT WAS
BUT I SHOULD HAVE SAID THAT MANY
OF THESE WOMEN DID STAY ON WITH
THE WORK AFTER THE WAR.
WE DIDN'T ROLL UP OUR CODE
BREAKING AFTER WORLD WAR II
BECAUSE THE COLD WAR STARTED SO
WE WOULD BE BREAKING EAST
GERMAN, RUSSIAN, CHINESE
COMMUNIST COLD SYSTEMS AND MANY
WOMEN DID STAY WITH THE WORK AND
WENT TO WORK ULTIMATELY FOR THE
NSA.
SO YOU SAW -- SHE WOULD RISE TO
BECOME THE FIRST FEMALE DIRECTOR
OF NSA AND IN FIRST SUPER GRADES
NSA WOMEN COMING OUT OF THE WAR.
SO THERE WAS AN IMPORTANT COHORT
OF WOMEN WHO HELPED ESTABLISH
THAT AGENCY.
>> I'M CURIOUS, HOW DOES THE
NAVY STEAL SOMEONE FROM THE ARMY
AND ALSO CORRESPONDENCE COURSE
IN CODE BREAKING NOW PUBLIC?
>> YES, SO THE CORRESPONDENCE
COURSES CAN BE FOUND AT THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES, THEY STILL
EXIST AS PAPER RECORDS, I'M SURE
THERE WAS AN UPDATED MODERN
VERSION BUT YOU CAN FIND THE
ONES FROM 1942.
I DID STUDY THEM WHEN I WAS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT
WORKED.
AND THE WAY THE NAVY STOLE HER
FROM THE ARMY WAS IT PAID MORE
MONEY.
BECAUSE SHE HAD A -- SHE HAD A
COLLEGE DEGREE SO SHE KNEW SHE
COULD GO INTO NAVY AS OFFICER
AND GET AN OFFICER'S ALLOWANCE,
IT WASN'T THE SALARY WAS MORE
BUT SHE COULD GET OFFICER'S
ALLOWANCE FOR HOUSING AND THAT
MORE MONEY, $50 OR WHATEVER IT
WAS ENABLED HER TO BUY A CAR.
THE OTHER GOAL IN LIFE WAS TO
SEE ALL THE CONTINENTS IN THE
WORLD WHICH SHE DID BUT SHE WAS
WITH HER -- ABLE TO DRIVE TO THE
WEST COAST AND THAT WAS
THRILLING FOR HER.
>> I JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION.
WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL WAS GIVEN THE
CODE TO BREAK DOWN, DID THEY
ALREADY -- WERE THEY WORKING
LIKE FROM TEMPLATE SO OKAY IF
THIS IS X IT'S B, THIS IS A 4
MEANS THAT OR LITERALLY BREAKING
DOWN THE CODE ITSELF?
>> THEY WERE BREAKING THE
MESSAGE SO THEY WOULD GET THE
MESSAGE AND THEY WOULD SEE THE
MESSAGE, BUT THEY WERE -- SOME
OF THE SYSTEMS WERE NUMERICAL
AND THEY HAD TO DO MATH, SOME OF
THEM WERE THEY WOULD BE LOOKING
AT LETTERS SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
VARIATION AND THEY HAD TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PARTICULAR
SYSTEM AND BREAK IT IN REAL
TIME.
SO THE TRAINING COURSES GOTTEN
AT COLLEGES OFTEN REALLY HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE ACTUAL
CODE SYSTEMS THAT THEY HAD TO
WORK ON.
THEY HAD TO LEARN T ON THE JOB,
THERE WAS SO MUCH INNOVATION AND
CHANGE TAKING PLACE DURING THE
WAR.
>> WERE THERE ANY WOMEN YOU
WANTED TO INTERVIEW OR THAT YOU
WISH YOU COULD HAVE INTERVIEWED
THAT HAD ALREADY PASSED ON?
>> OH, YEAH, THAT'S WHY I WAS SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE ORAL HISTORIES
AND COLLECTIONS AT THE LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS.
IT WAS FRUSTRATING BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THE INTERVIEWER
WOULDN'T ASK THE QUESTION THAT I
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE KNOWN.
AND ONE OF THE WOMEN TALKED
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE OF LOSING
HER HUSBAND IN THE D TEHERANING.
HE'S A GLIDER PILOT AND IT WAS
-- D DAY LANDING.
SHE COULDN'T GO TO HIS FUNERAL
BECAUSE SHE WAS WORKING THOSE
MACHINES AND THEY HAD TO
CONTINUE AFTER LANDING BECAUSE
WE WERE GOING TO BE TRACING THE
GERMANS THROUGH EUROPE, THEY
WOULDN'T RELEASE THE WOMEN FROM
THEIR STATIONS SO SHE COULDN'T
GO TO HER HUSBAND'S FUNERAL, I
FELT LIKE THAT INTERVIEWER WAS
UP COMFORTABLE TALKING TO HER
ABOUT THAT LOSS BECAUSE SHE SAID
SHE LOVED HIM FOR THE REST OF
HER LIFE.
SO THERE WERE MOMENTS WHEN I
WISH THAT OBVIOUSLY I COULD HAVE
TALKED TO THE WOMEN IN PERSON
BUT I WAS SO GRATEFUL FOR THE
ORAL HISTORY COLLECTIONS.
>> DID YOU EVER HEAR BACK FROM
THE EDITOR WHO SAID IT WAS --
>> NO, BUT I HOPE HE'S
REGRETTING THOSE WORDS.
I ACTUALLY FOUND THEM VERY
MOTIVATING SO IF ANY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE LISTENING OR
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND TEACHER
SAYS YOU CAN'T DO THAT OR
THERE'S A YOUNG WOMAN OUT THERE
WHO SAYS YOU KNOW, YOU SHOULDN'T
GO INTO STEM, DON'T LISTEN TO
THEM.
AND USE IT AS A MOTIVATION
BECAUSE I GOT UP EVERY MORNING
THINKING OKAY, I'LL SHOW YOU.
SO THE BOOK HAS BEEN AUCTIONED
AND I'M TOLD THAT THERE WERE A
LOT OF STAGES IT HAS TO GO
THROUGH BUT THERE IS, HIDDEN
FIGURES HAS BEEN WONDERFUL FOR
WOMEN'S STORIES, CONVINCING
PUBLISHERS AND STUDIOS THAT
THERE IS AN APPETITE FOR WOMEN'S
STORIES.
WE HAVE PEOPLE LIKE REECE WITHER
WITHERSPOON TALKING ABOUT WOMEN
FRONTED NARRATIVES SO I'M
OPTIMISTIC.
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO SEE.
>> I WAS CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR
PROCESS LIKE DID YOU FIND ALL
THE INFO BEFORE OR DID YOU HAVE
SOME NARRATIVE THAT IT FIT INFO?
>> THAT IS SUCH A GREAT
QUESTION.
SO NORMALLY I WOULD HAVE SPENT
TIME READING BOOKS ABOUT CODE
BREAKING, I WOULD HAVE SPENT
TIME IN THE PAPER RECORDS TO
EDUCATE MYSELF AND THEN I WOULD
HAVE GONE TO THE WOMEN.
WHEN I HAD A REALLY THOROUGH
GROUNDING BUT BECAUSE OF MY
ACTUARIAL, BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
MID 90s, I WANTED TO BE DONE
FIRST.
WHILE TALKING TO THEM I WOULD BE
WONDERING IF I WOULD BE ABLE TO
FIND AN ACTUAL PRINTED RECORD
THAT WOULD SUBSTANTIATE THEIR
MEMORIES.
AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER IT
WOULD BE OUT THERE AND AGAIN I
WAS AMAZED AT HOW MUCH THERE WAS
IN THE,NANAL ARCHIVES AND
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS THAT ENABLED
ME TO SUBSTANTIATE.
YOU SAW ANN STEELLY, SHE
REMEMBERED A SHOW THE WIKI
MESSAGE, A NOON POSITION
MESSAGE, THE JAPANESE NAVAL
CAPTAINS WOULD SEND A MESSAGE
SAYING WE'LL BE AT NOON NEXT DAY
DAY, A PIECE OF INFORMATION FOR
A AMERICAN SAW MARINE COMMANDER
TO HAVE.
WHEN I GOT THE FOR ARCHIVES I
FOUND MESSAGES ALL OVER THE
PLACE, REMARKABLE HOW ACCURATE
THEIR MEMORIES WERE.
I HAD TO DO IT BACKWARDS.
>> ARE THERE LISTS OF PEOPLE WHO
WORKED IN THOSE GROUPS THAT I
KNOW A NUMBER OF PEOPLE PROBABLY
WONDER AND WOULD LIKE TO LOOK UP
A NAME OR SOMETHING?
>> GREAT QUESTION.
THERE AREN'T GOOD -- THERE'S NOT
A SINGLE GOOD ROSTER.
I WISH NSA HAD RESOURCES OR THE
CRYPT LOGIC MUSEUM HAD
RESOURCES.
THEY HAVE MORE FUNDING, I'M THEY
WOULD TRY TO PUT TOGETHER A
ROSTER.
THEY'RE SCRAMBLE FILES I MIGHT
SEE SOME OF THE WOMEN WHO CAME
DOWN IN 1942 WHERE THEY WERE
LIVING AND -- BUT THERE'S NO ONE
CENTRAL PLACE THAT WE -- WHERE
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE NAMES.
IF THERE'S SOMEBODY IN YOUR
FAMILY OR EVEN SOMEBODY YOU KNOW
WHO MIGHT HAVE DONE THIS WORK OR
SAID SHE WAS A SECRETARY DURING
THE WAR, THAT INFORMATION, THOSE
PERSONNEL RECORDS ARE PUBLIC.
I HAVE A WEBSITE,
WWW.LIZAMUNDY.COM, I HAVE A TAB
FOR RESOURCES FOR CODE BREAKSER
AND FAMILIES.
YOU CAN REQUEST ANYBODY'S
WARTIME PERSONNEL RECORD AND
FIND OUT, IF THEY WERE A
CRYPTOGRAPHER OR CRYPTOLOGIST,
THAT MEANS THEY DID THIS WORK.
YOU CAN GET THEIR BACKGROUNDS
RECORDS, COLLEGE TRANSCRIPTS,
IT'S KIND OF REMARKABLE WHAT'S
AVAILABLE AND IT'S NO HARD.
-- IT'S NOT HARD.
>> WHAT WAS THE SEED OR THE IDEA
THAT DREW YOU TO WRITE THIS
STORY?
>> MANY FEDERAL AGENCIES HAVE
WONDERFUL HISTORY OFFICES AND
HISTORIANS THAT GENERATE AND
RECORD THE HISTORY OF THEIR
AGENCY.
SO THE NSA KNEW ITS ORIGIN STORY
INCLUDED THESE WARTIME WOMEN AND
JUST AS NASA KNEW ITS ORIGIN
STORY INCLUDED THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN MATHEMATICIANS.
SO I READ A DECLASSIFIED HISTORY
OF SMALL CODE BREAKING PROJECT
DURING THE WAR WRITTEN BY NSA
HISTORIAN, IT WAS OUT ON THE
INTERNET, IT HAD BEEN
DECLASSIFIED IT MENTIONS THIS
WAS RUSSIAN COLD
RUSSIAN CODE BREAKING THAT
MENTION AD LOT OF PEEP WORKING
THAT PROJECT WERE WOMEN, A LOT
FORMER SCHOOLTEACHERS FROM THE
SOUTH.
THAT SEEMED REALLY INTRIGUING.
SO I MADE AN APPOINTMENT TO
SPEAK WITH AN NSA HISTORIAN WHO
WAS EXTREMELY HELPFUL TO ME AND
A COURT RAYTOR AT THE CRYPT
LOGIC MUSEUM WHICH IS ATTACHED
TO NSA AT FORT MEAD, TWO WOMEN,
AND IT WAS THOUGH THEY HAD BEEN
WAITING FOR SOMEBODY TO COME
ALONG WHEN WAS INTERESTED AND
THEY SAT WITH ME FOR TWO HOURS
AN  EXPLAINED THE LARGER STORY
THAT WAS MOSTLY WOMEN BREAKING
JAPANESE AND GERMAN CODES DURING
THE WAR AND THEN I JUST HAD TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER I COULD FIND
PEOPLE AND FIND ARCHIVAL
RECORDS.
SO SHOUT OUT TO FEDERAL AGENCY
HISTORIANS, THEY ARE WONDERFUL.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO THANK YOU SO MUCH, I THINK
WE HAVE DESCENDENTS OF CODE
GIRLS IN THE AUDIENCE AS WELL
AND I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
THEIR FAMILY'S CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OUR HISTORY.
[APPLAUSE]